[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
peloton and I'd heard about peloton over
and over again but I ended up getting a
peloton bike in the whole system after I
saw my buddy Kevin Rose I've known him
forever some of you know and he showed
up at my gate at my house a while back
and he looked fantastic I asked him as a
dude you look great what the hell have
you been up to because he's always doing
a weird diet or another but it only
lasts like a week or two so he always
regresses to the mean after like 75
beers and he said I've been doing
peloton five days a week
now that caught my attention cuz Kevin
does nothing five days a week and you
know I love you Kevin but it really
piqued my curiosity ended up getting a
system and it's become an integral part
of my week I love it and I really didn't
expect to love it at all because I find
cycling really boring usually but
peloton is an indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home you don't worry about fitting
classes in your schedule or making it to
a studio with some type of commute etc
new classes are added every day
and this includes options led by elite
New York City instructors in your own
living room you can even livestream
studio classes taught by the world's
best instructors or find your own
favorite class on demand and in fact
Kevin and I rarely do live classes and
you can compete with your friends which
is also fun
Kevin I'm coming after you but we
usually just use classes on demand I
really like Matt Wilbur's and his eyen
high-intensity training sessions that
are shorter like 20 minutes and I think
Kevin's favorite is Alex and everyone
seems to have their favorite instructor
or you can select by music duration and
so on each peloton bike includes a 22
inch HD touchscreen performance tracking
metrics I think that
along with the real-time leaderboard are
the main reasons that this caught my
attention when cycling never had caught
my attention before it's really pretty
stunning what they've done with the user
interface to keep your attention the
belt drive is quiet and it's smaller
than you would expect so it can fit in a
living room or in office I actually have
it in a large closet believe it or not
and it fits with no problem so peloton
is offering all of you guys listeners of
the Tim Ferriss show a special offer and
it is actually special visit one peloton
that's Oh n e PE l OT o n 1 peloton calm
and enter the code Tim all caps TI m at
checkout to receive $100 off accessories
with your peloton bike purchase now you
might say mat accessories wait I don't
need fancy towels or whatever other
supplemental bits and pieces no the
shoes you need you need the clip in
shoes and those are in the accessory
category so this $100 off is a very
legit hundred dollars off so if you want
to get in your workouts if you want a
convenient and really entertaining way
to do high-intensity interval training
or anything else or you just want to get
a fantastic gift for someone
check out peloton one pallet on.com and
enter the code to Tim again that's Ont
PE l o t-- o-- n dot-com and enter the
code Tim a check out to receive $100 off
any accessories including the shoes that
you will want to get check it out
one peloton comm code Tim
this episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com
I love WordPress I have used it for so
many years it's my go-to platform for
blogging and creating websites I use
wordpress.com for everything every day
my site Tim not blog is built on it the
websites for my books including tools of
titans tribe of mentors it's all on
wordpress.com and the founder matt
mullenweg
when my close friends has appeared on
this show many times
just search matt mullenweg tequila
Ferriss for quite an exciting time
whether you're looking to create a
personal blog a business site or both
you can make a really big impact right
out of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be in good
company it's used by the New Yorker
jay-z Beyonce 5:38 TechCrunch Ted CNN
and time just to name a handful and one
of my friends at Google shall remain
nameless has told me that wordpress.com
offers the quote best out-of-the-box SEO
imaginable end quote and it's one of the
many reasons that nearly 30% of the
Internet is run on WordPress you do not
need experience or to hire someone
that's perhaps the best part
wordpress.com guides you through the
entire experience they have hundreds of
designs and templates that you can use
and it's easy to get started there's no
need to worry about security upgrades
hosting any of that they offer 24/7
support and they're very very responsive
if you have questions they get right
back to you and this allows you to
create the highest quality with the
least amount of headache and friction so
if you're building a website period when
my friends come to me and ask what I use
what I recommend they use the answer is
wordpress.com so check it out if you
want to get started today learn more
with a 15% discount off any new plan go
to wordpress.com forward slash Tim to
create your website and find the plan
that's right for you to learn more take
a look
wordpress.com forward slash Tim for a
15% off a brand new website check it out
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Paris and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where it
is my job to deconstruct world-class
performers of all different types across
all different industries and areas of
expertise in this episode we have Jason
freed on Twitter at Jason free Fri Edie
Basecamp calm he is the co-founder and
CEO of Basecamp previously known as
37signals a chicago-based
software firm the company's flagship
product Basecamp which I've used for
many many years is a project management
and team communication application
trusted by millions he is also the
co-author of getting real subtitle the
smarter faster easier way to build a
successful web application which is
available for free at getting real
37signals calm he is also the co-author
of the New York Times bestseller rework
and remote subtitle office not required
there's also a new book coming soon it
doesn't have to be crazy at work and you
can actually thread those together to
tell a lot of this story Jason rice
regular column for ink magazine and is a
frequent contributor to base camps
popular blog popular as an
understatement signal versus noise which
offers quote strong opinions and shared
thoughts on design business and tech end
quote Jason welcome to the show
thanks for having me Tim and we have we
have traded so many email over the years
and certainly met on a handful of
occasions and you have to be one of the
most requested guests for this podcast
so I'm thrilled that you were able and
willing to make the time so many thank
you to everybody who wanted to hear me I
don't know why but it's great to hear
that I'm wanted well I think part of why
people like to hear from you and maybe
it's a love-hate thing but I think that
what you said to me before we started is
indicative so one was in response to
what I always say to guests and that is
you have final cut so it's better to
kind of go a little over the edge and we
can pare it back later and you said
actually I don't want that much control
whatever I say should go out into the
world in effect is what you said and you
are known for being very raw and
contrarian which which I think has great
appeal to a lot of people particularly
in the current climate that we don't
need to describe for everybody to
understand and I'll start given that
with the quote from Jeff Bezos the
trillionaire in the making
behind Amazon quote Jason is immune to
dogma and has much to teach in 37signals
he has built an elegant company with
elegant products based on the idea that
less is more now of course this is
before we went from 37signals
to Basecamp but I'd love to talk about
this this immune to dogma component and
we could certainly talk about less is
more Jeff ended up investing in your
company which is a whole separate story
that we've covered in some respects with
the conversation I had with your you're
a partner in crime DHH separately so we
won't dig into that but what I'm really
curious to know is this immune to dogma
ability to question assumptions how much
of that is an innate skill versus an
acquired skill I guess it's hard for me
to say from where I said but I think a
big part of it is that I don't really
pay attention to a lot of things
actually so maybe I have different
points of view because I haven't heard
the other ones or I I had different
points of view because I haven't let you
know society's norms and the general
point of view get into my head so I have
to come up with my own ideas I've always
sort of I pay attention to some degree
but I'm pretty oblivious to a lot of
things intentionally because I don't
want to be influenced that much and it's
one of the reasons why I don't read
industry news I read very little news in
general but I definitely don't read
industry news I don't want to know what
everyone else is doing I find it's very
easy to end up following and being like
everybody else when you're constantly
hearing what everyone else has on their
mind it's very hard than to fight
against that so by not filling my mind
with other people's ideas I have nowhere
to go but to follow my own and I think
that perhaps that's why I'm immune to
two dogmas I just don't even pay
attention to you you just don't have as
much exposure yeah
yeah what are some of the parameters or
rules for yourself structures systems
anything that you've put in place to
find that sweet spot of deliberate
selective ignorance so to speak yeah a
lot of it is just kind of going with the
flow and not having I don't have a lot
of structure for example I I don't have
routines I don't I don't have any goals
I've never had any goals the goals are
not something that I pay attention to I
just sort of do what I feel like is the
right thing to do in any given situation
and I don't I don't look long-term at
things other than I want to for example
be in business over the long term I'd
like to live over the long term I'd like
to be nice and getting better over the
long term but I don't have a goal posts
along the way so because of that and
because they don't have much of a
routine I sort of just take it as it
comes and I think that also perhaps
allows me to sidestep a lot of the ways
you're supposed to do things you know
and because I don't plan it because I
don't think too far ahead on any
individual one thing I just able to sort
of go where I need to when I need to and
I know that's it's it's funny because
I'll talk to a lot of people about this
and people come on you must have some
goals like you know this or that and I
really really don't have any and I can't
remember ever having one I I just do the
best I can at any given situation and
that's the best I can do and however
that ends up playing itself out over
time is how it ends up playing itself
out over time I I don't want to measure
up one of my favorite quotes is um I
forget know who it is
maybe it's Mark Twain but you know he's
probably said everything or everything's
attributed to him but could it could
have been
it could have been a blinkin yeah
basically comparison is the death of joy
and I love that quote because it comes
down to people it comes down to
situations and it also comes down to
goals and setting goals for me I don't
want to compare myself to an idea I had
two years prior you know of where I
wanted to be I don't know where I'm
gonna want to be in two years so to set
a goal that's long-term in some cases
you're actually setting it for you know
who you are when you set it versus who
you are when you're gonna get there and
that's something that friend of mine
told me once and I thought guy named Jim
coud although I thought which is it's a
wonderful quote I don't know if it's his
or someone else's but it really rang
true and so that's kind of how I how I
go about the world well let's let's look
at that in a real-world example because
this is this is something that is I'm
sure you've experienced and as you noted
people react to with a certain level of
disbelief right you have a a profitable
company 17 out of 17 years or now what I
read may be out of date but however many
years out of however many years yeah and
you have an organization I you are
successful certainly by almost any
objective measure what did the last week
look like we're recording this on a
Thursday afternoon so we're coming up to
the tail end of what most people would
consider a business week and if you
don't have goals you must have some
means of making better decisions versus
shitty decisions so could you maybe walk
us through what this week has looked
like for you how you've spent your time
which yeah I know is very broad that we
perhaps use that as a launching point
yeah this week is a little tricky
because I had some personal stuff that I
had to deal with in the beginning a week
so we'll take like blast of the week
before or something like that perfect so
you know at Basecamp
we work in what we call six weeks cycles
so we are we don't work on anything okay
I'm generalizing but for the most part
we don't work on anything that takes
longer than six weeks to do so our goals
technically are to deliver
something great within six weeks
whatever we're building as an
organization that's sort of where our
goals are but our I don't have personal
goals like I don't have a goal like if
we we don't set personal go we don't
like company-wide goals in terms of like
this feature will be successful if or
you know it if it brings in this amount
of money it'll be worth it or anything
like that our our goal if you do want to
use the word is just to do the best job
we can so last week I was met with a
couple teams who are doing some projects
and kind of reviewed them with them and
tried to help them through some problems
work through some ideas we're just
finalizing some some some stuff on her
book so I'm working on the book that
we're finishing our manuscript is due in
a couple weeks
so I did some of that but but really
it's all about what we're actually doing
at the moment versus sort of the big
picture as to why we're doing it other
than we just want to do a good job we
have an idea we set out set out some
work we're gonna do over the next six
weeks and just helping people get there
and do the best we can and also make
decisions and cut things and say we
can't do all these things we want to do
what what's the important part of this
so I love trying to get to what's the
most important part of something versus
you know we don't have any for example
we don't have any KPI is at Basecamp we
don't have key performance indicators
yeah I didn't even know what that meant
by the way until recently because I
heard everyone talking about them I'm
like what do we have those and they go
oh no we don't have those just to pause
for a second so four people are like
what TPS reports so kpi's KPIs are
referred to very often in start-up
vernacular particularly in the tech
world as key performance indicators
which refer to the few or handful of
metrics that are prized and most valued
within your company and that that could
be revenue per employee it could be
monthly unique users or any number of
other things week on week growth of X
who knows so sorry to drink but just for
people who don't come from that world
you don't have Cape Cape kpi's don't
have that we don't have revenue growth
number targets we don't have we don't
okay so we don't have goals that we
don't have targets we don't have kpi's
we don't have sort of those kinds of
reasons for doing what we do every day
the reason we do what we do every day is
because we enjoy doing it and we want to
make what we're working on better and
we're making the thing that we're making
for others were also making for
ourselves so we technically want to make
our own tooling better because it helps
us do a better job with what we do so it
really is this day to day a week to week
or every six weeks sort of rolling thing
where you you you set out some stuff you
want to do you do it the best you can at
the end of those six weeks we take a
week or two off from scheduled work and
we do other things at work we roam
around have new ideas play with some
stuff and then we pick another set of
projects and over the next six weeks we
just kind of go as we go and
course-correct as we go and we just
don't have any of these big big picture
things so my weeks look like feedback my
weeks will look like thinking they look
like writing sometimes it requires me to
debate things internally with people you
know to lay out some some reasons for
why we're doing things but my week is
not pointed in any one direction other
than what we're really doing right now
so it is very much a day-to-day sort of
existence which which is why it's sort
of an incompatible existence with goals
with long-term goals you know with with
with figures and numbers and so I also
don't want to be upset about
expectations so another thing I don't
have or any really any expectations I
would hate to for example let's say
let's say the company was we were
expected to grow 22% next year I'm
making up numbers here right and we grew
21 like that would be a reason it a lot
of company needs to be upset that is a
ridiculous reason to be upset when you
set off these numbers in these goalposts
in these goals and these expectations
and you don't hit them then you're just
then you're upset and once you actually
either hit them or not hit them then you
come up with another set and you just
keep moving these these these moments of
possible joy but most likely
disappointment in a lot of cases and I
just don't feel like setting those up
for myself so I just ignore the whole
thing okay
I've all of these
various bits and pieces that I've
gathered through research and I suspect
that I'm just gonna get hung up on a
couple of things I really want to
explore and that's just gonna be the way
it goes let's go into it alright so
there are many people listening who are
familiar with these camp and the blog
and so on and are saying I would love to
have a company or a product as
successful as base camp but I don't know
how to go from where I am which is goal
oriented having kpi's etc to perhaps the
other end of the spectrum which is
closer to Jason so it's suppose embedded
into that is the is the question of
should they even want to emulate that
but but secondly if someone said yes
I've decided I want to move more in that
direction what might be a step they
could take or steps they could take to
inch them a little bit closer to where
you are and a little further away from
oh my god I wanted to hit 22 we we hit
21 we're a failure right well first off
I do want to make it really clear that
this is simply what works for me in our
organization so I am NOT suggesting this
is the only way the best way whatever
this this works for us so if if what
works for you works for you and your
very goal oriented and KPI driven and
you think you know you need to the
things you measure the thing or whatever
it is that show you how that saying goes
what you what you measure is what you
move or whatever I don't know what gets
measured gets managed that's the one
right so so if you're if you're like
that and and you think that things are
great for you and things are working
well for you please do not even consider
changing like keep doing that I think
though if you're doing all those things
and you feel a sense of sort of a lack
of fulfillment or your may be
consistently disappointed or you're
reaching for things that you can't seem
to grab I would suggest you know trying
a little bit trying some of the things
I'm suggesting which is pull back your
expectations a bit just sort of try to
set out to do the best you can versus
try to measure up with a number that
you've made up and that's the other
thing
I think is important here is that any
projection that you set out to hit is a
guess
like your your you you personally are
making or someone in your organization
whatever is making a guess and they're
picking a number and they're saying this
is where we think we should be because
this is sort of what we did last year
and because of that we want to do a
little bit better this year and but all
the stuff is still just man-made now
none of these things are are inherent in
existence they're all man-made things
these numbers these goals is figure so
if you can begin to strip that back and
sort of recognize that that's the case
and say like what if I tried to function
without setting any of these but I just
did the best work I can anyway cuz isn't
that what I should be doing anyway no
matter what so my suggestion would be as
with anything I'm not a big fan of
trying to massively change anything at
once so I think um my suggestion would
be like whatever the next project you
have that you're working on if you would
normally set out some goal posts or set
out some some figures to hit or whatever
or measure this just try not measuring
one of those things just take pick one
little tiny thing that you can throw
away and not worry about and see what
happens and you'll probably find that
the sky isn't falling and the business
isn't correct isn't crashing and people
aren't running aimlessly around not
wondering what - wondering what to do
that actually in fact people will if you
if you explain why you're doing it
because you want to make this better
because simply you want to make it
better and you think it could be better
or whatever and you lay that out that
people will be motivated enough by that
that that that the numbers and the
figures don't necessarily they're not
the things that are pulling you forward
what's pulling you forward hopefully is
your intrinsic motivation and your and
your desire to do a better job at what
you're doing and the sort of
appreciation of the craft and the
respect of the work that you're doing
and who you're doing it for that that's
kind of enough and that everything else
is sort of a side effect of that so
anyway I'd say pick one little thing
throw it away don't worry about it and
see what happens you'll probably find
out that everything's just okay and then
maybe you'll have the courage to try it
with another little thing that you are
measuring that you don't really care so
much about and I know I'm well aware
that this flies in the face of a lot of
people's worldview and maybe even yours
I know you're big into measuring things
especially health
wise and whatnot so again I think it
comes down to also most importantly
knowing who you are and what what
matters to you and not trying to be like
somebody else there's a lot of people
trying to be like other people and I
don't want anyone to try and be like me
you should be like yourself and if
there's 5% of what I'm saying makes
sense to you then maybe you can pull
that in and make that part of you too
but I don't think you should be out
there trying to be someone else because
that's a bit of an artificial situation
you may be you've you've mentioned
directly and alluded to perhaps a few
things I'd like to underscore just for
folks listening the first is that when
you when one reads a quote or here's a
quote like what gets measured gets
managed it can often be taken to me and
that you should manage everything and
therefore you should measure everything
and that there is only upside in
measuring but that's simply not the case
and for instance whether it's the I
remember and you grow of I believe it
was of Intuit talking about how for
every metric that you track and hold
people accountable for you have to
include identify and then also assess
the perverse incentive you've created by
imposing that metric so if if people
respond to incentives and you create a
metric humans being humans they will
look for easier and easier ways to say
goose that number up or chop that number
down and you have to be aware of what
that does to their behavior and so on
within the company but secondly
measurement there there are things worth
measuring and then there are things not
worth measuring that can become vanity
metrics that people use just to feel
productive instead of being productive
and just to point to one thing that you
mentioned which I think a lot of people
would assume of me that that is I I
physically track a lot of things all the
time and not say you assume that but
there is a point to my tracking which is
identifying what works for say my
physiology what harms me based on my
genotype or whatever it might be and
then and then I just stop the vast
majority of measurement and do it very
intermittently right so the the the
follow-up to that I'd love to ask for
people since you mentioned you don't
read much if any trade publications or
news what do you read what are you
reading and maybe that's another
opportunity for people to pare back on a
like I say thoughtless it's too
judgmental but a a habit that perhaps
consumes a lot of time without adding
much value so what do you what do you if
not that kind of stuff what type of
stuff do you read and what are you what
have you been reading recently or what
are you reading yeah let me get to that
one second but I had a thought about the
previous question sort of the genesis of
this for me is I used to do a lot of
jogging I still do a little bit but I
kind of had some knee surgery a while
ago and so I've sort of not been doing
it as much but I remember trying to hit
certain times like I want to you know
run a six-and-a-half minute mile or
whatever it was at the time and you know
I'd go out and I'd run a six-minute mile
and 42 seconds and I remember being
disappointed by that and and I remember
feeling like white why should I be
disappointed in that I'm not running a
race I'm not competing against anybody
I'm sort of competing as myself but I
set that up for myself that's not
something I had to do like I created
that moment to be upset what if I just
went out and ran because I enjoy running
and just kind of run the best I can
every time I run and and just do that
and I found that I started doing that
and I enjoyed it more and it didn't mean
I didn't run faster or slower
I didn't even necessarily know and it
didn't really matter I could feel
whether or not like it was a good run
like that was a good run I had a good
run today was sort of a much better way
to figure out my sort of satisfaction
than to measure it and say it was a six
minute and 40
two minute run versus a six minute 38
second run and I think that that's kind
of where it sort of came into play for
me in business too so I think I pulled
it from that I wanted to share that
because I just remembered that that that
was sort of a moment and I remember how
old I was when I did that was probably
actually in high school or early in
college or something where I started to
think that way and that's maybe where
that where that came from too but anyway
I want to get that in there um reading
what do I read well you know I started
reading the paper more which is like the
newspaper not not online news sources
but actually the newspaper and this
happened because I was in a hotel this a
few years ago is it a hotel and you know
you go to a hotel and they ask you check
in and they say you know Joe would you
like a newspaper and I used to always go
to another newspaper who reads
newspapers anymore cuz I get all my news
on the internet which is instant all the
time and the thing is most of that's not
actually news it's entertainment I think
the news like once a day is actually a
perfectly good pace for the news so if
you get the news in the morning
you're basically getting all of
yesterday's stuff that happened in the
world that wasn't that someone you know
some editors decided was important and
and and they just said they put that in
the news they print it and the next
morning you get it and then if you wait
another full day to get the news again
pretty good chance that you didn't miss
anything
actually by paying attention to things
all the time very few things happen
during the middle of the day that you
really absolutely need to know that you
can't wait for the next morning to know
and so I've realized that the newspaper
is actually a better way to get the news
because it's better the pace is better
it prevents you from searching and
seeking out news that you don't need to
know about necessarily it prevents you
from playing the the sport I call it the
sport of information like trying to know
more than everybody else and be like be
faster - the latest story and everybody
else that that's turning into a sport
and in fact the news is presented if you
watch any any news channel now it's
presented as a sport I mean you've got
these Chiron's going across the bottom
these graphics scrolling across you've
got Talking Heads that are so
of debating it you turn on ESPN or you
can turn on CNN and if you hit the logos
you wouldn't couldn't tell the
difference really
and so news cartridges turn into sports
coverage and vice versa and I just would
rather say like once a day is enough of
a general interval for me to be
relatively well informed about what's
really going on in the world also at the
resolution that matters I think the
other problem I'm having but I look at
Twitter and I click on links here and
there and I read some stuff that I like
but but for the most part I'm not trying
to find out what happened an hour ago
and that to me is actually the real
advantage to something like the
newspaper where you simply cannot find
out what happened an hour ago
because what happened an hour ago in
most cases doesn't matter now you could
say what if there's a national disaster
or a major tragedy your school shooting
and your kids at the school like there's
all sorts of moments of course where
real time truly does matter but for the
most part it doesn't matter at all and
in fact it's worse because you become if
there's the fear of missing out like III
think of it as it's jomo like the joy of
missing hours I'm happy took this out
yeah I mean that's in our new book okay
which is like it just it's great I don't
need to know all this stuff all the time
and and yeah again like look if there's
a there's a month I'm I'm in LA right
now if there's a mudslide like coming to
my house like I should know about that
right obviously but that's something
that might happen every you know
hopefully never and maybe once a decade
and to say that I need to be informed a
real time anything that could possibly
happen anytime because that one thing
might happen once that's just a recipe
for anxiety and I try to avoid that at
all costs definitely know I know you are
a fan to give one example of a book
titled seeking wisdom from Darwin to
Monto via by Peter bevel and could you
describe we're just explained why you
like that book which is also one that I
love it was actually sent to me by
Derek Siver's of all people folks can
look him up
Tim dog /c verse if you want to learn
more about him but seeking wisdom from
darwin to monger by Peter Devlin great
book can you explain why you like that
book and any other books that that
you're also fond of
yeah so it's been a while since I've
read that so a book review would be
really embarrassing but I'll tell you
this I love Charlie Munger and Warren
Buffett is the mattel of about those two
guys and of course this book is not
written by them but it's sort of the the
spirit of it which is this very clear
direct no [ __ ] way of writing this
very sort of simple folks enos that you
know what life really necessarily I mean
I know this is a broad generalization
but in most cases it's not that
complicated we tend to make things very
complicated we tend to make things very
hard on ourselves but really there's
some basic fundamentals of many things
that if you kind of understand those
you're in pretty good shape and you
don't need to go much further than that
and I love that kind of wisdom I love
old people in general aren't often
Charlie Munger I think mongers in his
90s now and Buffett's in his 80s but
they've always had this kind of wisdom
which is this old school almost Farmers
Almanac style wisdom and I've always
been attracted to that because I think
complexity has also become a sport where
it's like the more complicated something
is the better you know the better you
think you are at it like if you make it
more complicated you're better at it or
something and I just think it's kind of
the opposite so I love those guys in
that book to me sort of highlighted a
lot of that kind of thinking and so
anything that that mongers written I
love reading like Warren Buffett's
letter to a shareholders which i think
is a must read for anybody a hundred
percent agreed yeah yeah forget even
just business people just if you want to
read clear writing if you want to
understand what it's like to communicate
something at a high level
you've got to read what he writes so
that's the kind of stuff I love to read
I love to read I like Bezos to
shareholder letters as well for similar
reasons that's the kind of stuff I'm
really interested in I don't
read fiction at all and maybe I'm
missing out there but I I just my
argument is always that I feel like the
the world is so interesting on its own
that there's more than enough I can read
about real stuff I know some people are
gonna just hate me for this and I and I
always get hate on it but I I just would
rather to read biographies or I'd rather
read about nature I'd rather read about
that stuff because the world is
fascinating as it is so those are the
kinds of things I'm into these days and
you know I've been reading I know you're
deep into this now I've been doing a lot
about stoicism and beginning into that
so that the the is that the art of Joe
ancient art of joy or so what's that
yeah the art of joy by William says on
the wing or rather I'm blanking I'll put
it in the show notes here everybody
which is a compilation of both I suppose
excerpts and samples but also in
interpretations and applications of
stoic philosophy love I want to say
Levine William Irving maybe that's it
that's a yeah I think you're right I
think that's it so I read that recently
or last year and really loves that I've
been getting in a bit bit of that um I
know that's the kind of stuff I'm into
these days why is that um stoicism or
just nice stoicism yeah it just
resonates with me a few few basic things
by the way I don't need to go that deep
into it again it's not like I need to go
super deep and into the you know the
whole the whole world of it but
basically things like you know you you
pretty much only have control over your
reactions to things and I think that
that is that in itself is enough I could
stop there
III go further but I could stop there
and say that is extremely poignant
especially today I see people you know
getting so wound up about what other
people say what other people do and you
know when you when you begin to see that
what they're actually being wound up
about is their own reaction to that
thing not the thing itself the thing
itself you know yeah maybe it's terrible
maybe it's great whatever it is but it's
it's how you sort of respond to it and
how you allow it to affect you that's
deep and really important and I think
one of the best lessons I've learned in
the past few years so there's that
also just negative visualization I think
is a really wonderful tool and I paying
a lot of attention to that in my life
can you just for people who aren't
familiar with that would you mind
describing that just in brief what that
is negative visualization yeah as far as
I understand it at least it's basically
figuring out what the worst case
scenario might be in any given situation
and coming to terms with that and sort
of realizing it probably in many cases
it won't be as bad as you think it could
be so get used to the worst thing and
David and I talked about this
occasionally right so DHH and I talked
about this in the business like what if
we made some grave grave horrible errors
so business has been in business for
eighteen years and what if like or what
if the competition destroys us or
whatever like what if we actually go out
of business in two years like what if
that actually happens we don't want that
to happen what if it did like what's the
worst that would happen well it would be
terrible because a lot of people would
lose their jobs now would suck but we
think a lot of people who worked for us
would have no problem finding other jobs
so that wouldn't maybe be so bad I would
have no income and Dave would have no
income that would suck but we've done
pretty well for ourselves so we can live
we can live fine without that we
couldn't do what you love doing every
day well that would kind of suck but
maybe we could still do it just not in
that capacity and you know what a
20-year run isn't so bad like if we only
made it twenty years in business that
wouldn't be so bad either so just
thinking about like what would be the
worst thing that could possibly happen
and then you know recognizing that
probably will not happen it just helps
you I think calm down about that and
it's sort of avoid this constant set of
worries in some ways you sort of get all
the worrying out at once and then you go
about your day and go well if that
happens and it happens at least I know
what that's gonna feel like or what I
think that might feel like it's not that
it would eliminate all of the feelings
and there certainly would be other
negative feelings I may have missed but
for the most part I've thought it
through and I feel like I can probably
cope with it now if that actually
happens versus having something surprise
you
in the moment it having it be real that
can be really traumatic and really
difficult to handle so that's my general
understanding of that at least that's a
great start definitely I think it's a
great description and just by analogy I
was just thinking this so I'm sitting in
this room where I do a lot of recording
and I did a absolute that
a former MMA fighter but also Special
Forces sniper named Tim Kennedy and he's
a beast of a fighter and a fascinating
guy but he was saying Oh in my bag right
now I have X Y & Z firearm I have enough
first aid that I could patch you and the
videographer together if one of you had
an arm chopped off I'm looking at how I
could block the doorway in case of a B
and C and he's happy he knows exactly
how to assess the situation in specifics
and the reason that I bring that up is
as you were describing this negative
visualization I was thinking to myself
it's something akin metaphorically
speaking to taking of fear let's just
say you have a semi a nebulous fear of
something going wrong and let's say that
fears then embodied by a person and that
person says I'm going to destroy you and
then you run away and all day or all
week you're thinking oh my god that
person is going to destroy me how are
they gonna destroy me there's this
ambiguity that's really stress producing
but if you were to sit down with that
person say okay I know you're gonna
destroy me but I want to know exactly
how you're gonna destroy me like well
first like I'm gonna ambush you at the
corner of second in Colorado and I'm
going to try to hit you with this type
of bat you're like okay now I like know
where I know what they're gonna do I
have a I can start planning a response
right or they say you know I'm gonna
beat you to death with a nerf baseball
about you're like that's actually not
gonna beat me to death at all and and
you you start to realize how recoverable
a lot of this is almost yeah all of
these fears are either completely
unfounded or completely recoverable or
preventable and it's it's really
arguably the most valuable thing I have
learned from any type of reading of
philosophy is this negative
visualization which I tend to do in
written form a lot in an exercise that I
call fear setting which people can
google and find for free everywhere but
I'll stop my my my soapbox speech at
this point about
the fear setting and negative
visualization but it's extremely
powerful and I think this is
particularly true at least in my
experience if you come from a family as
I did of worriers people who spent a lot
of time focused on the future with a
high baseline of anxiety and whether
that is innate to my code to my DNA or
simply an adopted set of behaviors and
beliefs and thought patterns I don't
know maybe it's a combination but it's
it's really been hugely hugely helpful
yeah you know I feel like that's similar
I I feel like I worried a lot I still do
I still battle with this and I do kind
of feel like it is a battle actually in
a sense with worrying in I don't stop
worrying about myself but I have a three
and a half year old now so I worry I
will worry about him and I find myself
realizing that like kids are actually
really quite resilient and I shouldn't
be worrying so much that things are
gonna be just fine
and it's actually a really good practice
for me to to use anger visual negative
visualization when I'm worrying about
things like oh he's gonna go go to
school and get sick and then he's gonna
the flu and I'm gonna get the flu and if
I get the flu then I can't do this and
they're all hot my wife's gonna get the
flu and she's pregnant and then like you
go through all this stuff and it's like
yeah that could happen and you know I
can't you can't stop it I can't prevent
like kids go to school they get sick and
like you might get sick and like okay
but if you think about how bad it can be
you start to really ruminate on it
versus like yeah that could happen and
if that happens it happens you just deal
with it and live with it and and but I
remember before I got into this negative
visualization I would actually worry a
lot and what's cool about negative
visualization I think is it clears the
worry out of the room in a sense like
you give it a worry like you worry about
it for a while and then it's and it's
over the worrying is over and I think
that's the key insight for me in it
which is it gives me a moment to say
yeah okay I'm gonna worry about this I'm
gonna worry about it as bad as it could
possibly be and think about how exactly
horrible it could be and then I can then
I'm done with that and that's the
difference compared to consistent
low-grade always on worry or you'd never
have that moment where you can really
confront it until it happens when it
usually doesn't definitely and I looked
I looked up the the title of the book
the author is William be her vine like
Irvine Californian that the title is a
joy Wow I can't even read it correctly
alright here we go
a guide to the good life subtitle the
ancient art of stoic joy and that's the
one and it is a fantastic introduction
to stoicism and by itself if you never
read another book on the subject
extremely extremely helpful yeah you
mentioned you mentioned your your son
right you have a son and you know I'm
curious if we if we turn back the clock
do you remember the first time you got
in trouble or any memorable early memory
of getting into trouble oh my god I got
into so much trouble when I was younger
the first time no I remember the first
time I cried so hard that I almost
couldn't breathe you know that crying
yeah I remember why that happened but
I'm sure I did something really bad and
and I think my my my parents like
reminded me how bad it was there's
something and I got really scared I
think I don't remember how well that was
but I remember that moment I but I I got
in a lot of trouble when I was younger
probably should have gotten in more
trouble I probably got away with too
many things as well but I I got I got
into a lot of trouble if my parents
would have to pick me up at the police
station when I was younger was that when
I was younger like I'm talking like 15
like that kind of thing for 14 junior
actually junior high was bad like was at
13 14 so I'm gonna there's somewhere in
there yeah yeah I was I was really bad I
kind of got in with a bad crowd and and
and started doing some bad stuff
although it wasn't so bad what type of
what were the offenses let's get
specific okay so it's actually
entrepreneurial stuff
side to side hustle yes I continue sorry
I'm just imagining the expression you
just made like the winds as I said yes I
don't know when the entrepreneurial bug
bit me but it bit me oh really
and I loved knives and like throwing
stars and like switchblades although I
couldn't get those because those are
illegal I just love that kind of stuff
how old are you you know what I'm asking
I probably today today 43 okay so yeah
weakness aware of the same vintage yeah
so I I had too much caffeine so I'm
interrupting you but the we grew up when
I can ninjas and breakdancing were yes
as cool as it could as cool as you could
possibly be and there was a catalog
called
Asian world of martial arts I don't
remember this yeah WMA yeah anyway just
to put some context so at that time
people like you and me it was not
infrequent that young guys definitely
mostly young guys would fantasize about
throwing stars and climbing claws and
grappling hooks so just oh man just to
set the stage yeah please continue
I somehow I don't remember how this
happened somehow maybe it was my dad who
got on this mailing list or I got ins
like we were starting to get these
catalogs at home and one of them was
that one another one was called
sportsmen guide there's a few other ones
where it's kind of like army surplus II
stuff and I don't really remember
exactly how it all happened but I
started looking through the pages and
there were these cool knives and
throwing stars and like some bullets
stick knives like knives you could
actually shoot with a spring like crazy
[ __ ] [ __ ] she's crazy stuff and I just
got into it and like tear gas and this
kind of weird [ __ ] so so as I mean a 13
year old boy for me it was just the
coolest thing in the world right I don't
know why but I was so into it until I
started to take these catalogs and make
Xerox copies of these pages and then cut
them out and then reassemble my own
catalog
and I would like reai wood I would kind
of scratch out the prices and like put
new prices on them and then make
catalogs which I would then distribute
to my friends friends then who would buy
these knives and stuff for me I would
then so I take these orders and I would
make an order form and everything and I
would take these things and this is back
in like 85 I got my first Mac in 85 and
so I was like using my Mac to like print
stuff out my image writer or ever I had
at the time and I'd make these catalogs
and these order forms and print the
stuff out and distribute it to some
friends and they would like make orders
I get that I get the cash from them they
everyone had like part-time jobs so they
give me some cash I get the cash I would
place an order through these catalogues
for this stuff I'd order its Co D
because which I don't they have that
anymore called cash on delivery I don't
think they have that anymore but I
didn't have a credit card for those of
you who are much younger and don't
remember or don't know what this was ups
could actually come to your to your
house bring a package and you would pay
the UPS driver the UPS driver then take
that money and put an envelope and then
send it back to the company that's how
you'd actually buy things sometimes so
anyway I get cash I'd order stuff Co D
ID fake that I was sick that day and
stay home from school I knew when it was
gonna be delivered the UPS driver would
come I would give him the cash and I get
these things and I distribute them to my
friends and I would make profit and then
I did that with like cigarettes and
chewing tobacco and all sorts of stuff
and so I kind of like Bennett then I had
a bit of a reputation as a pyro because
I love fireworks and fire and stuff so
I'd like anyway I got into a lot of
trouble eventually as you can imagine
selling contraband to 15 year old boys
in the suburbs of Chicago and then like
you know I kind of got in with the wrong
crowd and then like all sorts of weird
things happen at some point anyway
eventually like got that out of my
system but I that's how I started
getting into being an entrepreneurs is
that and I love the idea of carving up
other people's catalogs and making my
own and then I got a resellers license
somehow and got into electronics and
started be able to buy things that like
dealer cost from these big distributors
and then like
for example radar detectors so people
can my friends could speed and you know
16 so let's go speed let's go get a
radar detector in our car so I'd buy
writer detectors they'd like cost double
the price under my friends cuz they
couldn't get them and telephone like
cordless phones was a you know back then
like and then computer hard drives in
the early days and then computers and
that's kind of how I got into all this
stuff but it was it was it's funny
because like the way I think about
business today even the business I'm in
today base camp I just see it as a
continuation of when I was 13 sewing
knives
honestly like it's all one business
where I'm buying or making the thing
that I want and then finding other
people who want the same thing it's the
same business as it ever was when I was
13 and is today I'm not selling illegal
stuff now then that same spirit anyway
so I got in trouble I remember what you
know I got in trouble probably before
that today my parents let me get away
with a lot as an only child so I think
they'd let me get away with extra an
extra amount of stuff but those early
days I think paved the way for me to
really learn how to you know how to sell
things how to market things how to
promote things how to package things how
to mark things up and khana also charge
for things which is a strange way the
thing that's so deficient about our
industry today or the tech industry
which is like a lot of people they don't
all the companies don't charge for
anything they give stuff away for free
and then they have to live with all
these other the negatives of that which
were even seeing play out in the news
you know now something I learned a lot
of lessons from doing the wrong thing
let's say you make a bunch of weird
things happen we're not we don't
necessarily have to go into that
although I'm certainly happy to go into
one of them okay yeah yeah because I'm
you're like I got out of my system I'm
like well for a lot of people they never
quite get it out of their system so
there had to be I would imagine a
catalyzing event or events or something
that encouraged you to get so let's
let's go into one there wasn't there
were so first of all I had this friend I
won't mention his name but he was a bad
influence on me
my parents spotted him immediately said
this kids no good we don't want
want you to be with this kid but anyway
I still was because he was cool and I
want to be cool anyway one day during
lunch we put a like a tic-tac like a
mint it wasn't a tic-tac but some sort
of mint in this other kids milk okay at
school and after he drank his milk we
told him this again I'm so ashamed of
this whole thing but anyway we told him
that we poisoned him right you're 15 15
or something like yeah this is kind of I
mean I hate to say it not to excuse it
but sort of par for the course fifteen
year old boy behavior yeah it was shitty
but I'm just being honest so I did that
we obviously didn't poison anybody but
like we told him we did okay and it's
funny because we it wasn't a bullying
thing he was actually a friend of ours
so it wasn't like it wasn't like we were
picking on anybody he's like a friend of
ours and we did this anyway in math
class later that day he passes out
because he was probably anxious and
thought that we poison him so yeah he
has to get a stomach pumped because he
thought he told he told though it's like
he told the teachers then they'd like
the police got involved that he'd been
poisoned and I had to go down to the
police station I parent said that's like
taking the police station and all this
[ __ ] and it was like it was it was a
mint you know but it was it was we set
this up in a way where he didn't think
it was and so anyway that was some of
the [ __ ] I got into and eventually I got
into that and a couple of the things
eventually my parents said hey look
enough if you get in trouble again we're
sending you off to boarding school
which means your gut you're away from
all your friends and your way from us
and the whole thing and it was that
statement alone that changed everything
for me I don't know why either I I
didn't even know what boarding school
was it probably sounded kind of cool
like I get to go away and sleep away
like there's something kind of almost
cool about it in a sense like when you
don't really know what it would be but
they said it in such a stern way that it
was so clear that this was not where I
wanted to go and what I wanted to where
I wanted to be right the tone made it
clear it was not desirable for you yes
and that was the moment when I basically
I went back to my old friends were
awesome I never really left them but I
kind of
sorta did and and they were very cool
about it and they kind of welcomed me
back basically and I just stopped doing
all that [ __ ] I just stopped it and it
sounds like how how could I have just
stopped it but it's probably because I
wasn't really it was sort of this stunt
that I was pulling and not really what I
wanted to do is just kind of a fun thing
when I realized that there were
consequences and the ones I realize our
true consequences I changed and I think
that was kind of the thing for me is
that especially when I was younger I
would sort of do things I remember like
so I went to Hebrew school like after
school and then I hated it absolutely
hated it because it was like 2 hours
Tuesdays and Thursdays after school I
wasn't religious my parents weren't
really either but they sort of it was
just sort of something that everyone in
the neighborhood did and I kind of did
and was out of respect for my
grandparents who were more religious
anyway so I went to this thing like two
days a week after school and I would I
remember I remember my dad telling me
once it like because I was I was kind of
bad there - I was extra bad there I
would always like question the teachers
like well wait prove it can you prove
that God exists like stuff like that I
was just being an [ __ ] you know just
because I knew like you couldn't prove
it just being and so that was just like
a being difficult
anyway I got in trouble in my daddy so
surprising to hear and so my dad my
dad's like you know he's like you
shouldn't do this but I just want you to
know like none of this goes on your
record you know the record they always I
don't you ever I didn't have exactly
pristine record as a kids yes I had the
the record what I didn't know at the
time until my dad's like so my dad's
like you know this isn't gonna go on
your record and actually like made me do
more bad [ __ ] and eventually I got
kicked out at Ebru school for like doing
some other stuff which I really go into
for gross insubordination yeah basically
and they just had enough of me and they
knew I had enough of them and the whole
thing they let me like go through and
get my bar mitzva and they like let me
do that but they like just don't come to
school anymore okay
today's creative differences yeah so
anyway um all those things like at some
point I just I my parents kind of said
boarding school or you know stop her
this and I stopped and you know back
then I I you know I as high school kids
do he drink a bit and this like I got
that all on my system also like all that
stuff I kind of got out of my system and
that's kind of one of the reasons I
didn't really like college cuz in
college everyone was experimenting with
stuff for the first time in a sense I
feel like I'd already been through all
that and so the social experience in
college was was actually really boring
for me and and almost felt childish
actually because I felt like I'd been
through it when I was a child and now I
see everyone else doing that and so I
didn't really enjoy college at all for
that reason and I just sort of kind of
muddled through and got it done and then
by that point I was already doing a
website design like freelance I had a
software business that I'd already
started on the side selling software
that I made to organize my own music
collection and all the stuff I started
sort of doing in Timmy College was
actually just getting in a way of me
getting out there and doing the things
that I really wanted to do so you
mentioned organizing your music
collection and we could dig into that I
remember reading a story about it people
could send you in $20 to get audio file
right there yeah upload to AOL yeah so
read the story of getting this you were
getting this envelope from Germany or
some other country
the airmail envelope but I'm sure some
people have seen with the red and blue
around the edges and lo and behold right
order form $20 bill like big deal it was
that the first time that you were like
holy [ __ ] like I could do this or I'm an
entrepreneur or I'm successful like do
you remember of these many
entrepreneurial experiments and ventures
that you've been involved with was was
there a particular incident that stands
out like wow holy [ __ ] like this this is
something that I could actually make a
living doing I could do this
yeah the 20 well first of all I never
thought about making a living really but
I thought of
what was different about the the
software getting 20 bucks in the mail
for software that I made was it was the
first time I realized actually let me
step back I've been selling stuff before
I we talked about that like throwing
stars and that [ __ ] but I had to do work
for that like I had to work I had to
make a sale each time I had to get
inventory each time I would sell
inventory to have to get more inventory
I have to go out and convince my friends
to buy more [ __ ] right what was
different about the software thing was
that I could make this thing once I
could put it out there into the world
and a lot of people could pay me for it
and I could in a sense make money while
I was sleeping I didn't think about it
necessarily that way I do like I can
look back on it now and say that's what
I thought I didn't feel it that way but
what I did realize was that I could make
something that I wanted I could put a
lot of effort into it and put it out
there and let it speak for itself and if
people liked it they'd be happy to pay
for and that people are happy to pay for
things and that like I don't have to go
out and sell each one I could put it up
and people could buy it from all over
the world when they find it on their own
that was I think the distinctly
different thing for me at that moment
versus everything else I've done in the
past was sort of one-off sales including
like you know eventually I was doing
some like logo design and website gets
on which came little bit later after
well actually I'm not sure what the
timeline was but even that you have to
find a client every time and you got to
find someone new every time and the
whole thing and and software was
different and that's probably and that's
what I do today because I make software
we put it out there and technically
technically you're making money while
you're sleeping because it's running and
people pay you on a monthly basis and
you know you kind of make it once and
put it out there versus although of
course you're making it every day you're
changing it and tweaking it but it's you
know still the same spirit so that was
the big change for me I think and then
you know I realized that the deeper
realization though again is that like I
don't it I can make this for myself I
can satisfy myself and that then the
next step is to find other people like
you versus trying to dominate an
industry and I think this is a
fundamental thing that we have today at
base camp which is I have no interest DJ
should I talk about that we have no
interest in dominating anyone or
anything we don't land I'm not out for
land grab I don't know what our market
share is I could care less it doesn't
matter to me none of this stuff I'm not
looking to put any competitors out of
business I'm not looking to to to be
number one none of that stuff matters
what matters is and I make something
that I like can we put it out there to
support our costs and make more money
than we spend and if that means we have
one percent market share or 0.1 percent
market share fine with me I don't care
if it means we have a 50% market share
founded me I don't care none of that
matters what matters is kind of what can
I build something I like and can it be
sustainable and can't fund our our
continued development and endeavors and
that's also with the music thing because
I made it for myself I was loaning out
my CDs and tapes to friends and never
getting them back and I forgot who I
loved them too and I'm like well maybe
if I organize this I could like have an
inventory of all the stuff I have you
know bootlegs and CDs and the whole
thing and whenever I low went out to
someone I'll just like note the date and
who it was and then I'll build a system
that will send me a reminder about that
thirty days later and I can go hey hey
Bill remember that CD that I let you
have I said I need this weekend like I
still don't have it and then I would get
all my stuff back and so you know that's
kind of what would what I've been doing
ever since this is building stuff that
works for me so I want to tell a story
through your words about how the world
welcomed you with open arms and
immediately started buying everything
that you had to sell so I'd like to read
a bit of text here and I'm pretty sure
this is not a misquote since you typed
it out and sent it to me some time ago
here we go way back in the 90s when I
was getting started as web designer
I sent my work into an awards site
called high-five comm at the time it was
the [ __ ] if you were word at a high five
word you were recognized now I sent my
stuff in and I'm gonna leave his name
out just so I don't have anybody chasing
me around the guy who ran it emailed me
back I don't have the original email
anymore but basically he told me I
sucked I had no business being in the
web design business and that I should
never
again that rejection filled me with so
much fire not anger not resentment not
disappointment but fire fired to kick
ass and prove his impression wrong I
loved the rejection it made me and that
was in response to a question I asked
you which was how as a failure or a
parent failure say you have to later
success that was my last book driving
mentors and my question about this and
you can certainly take this anywhere you
want if you want to elaborate correct do
anything else but my question speaking
personally as someone who has struggled
with anger I mean I spent so much my
childhood being bullied really badly I
was born premature really really small
and with a lot of health issues up until
about sixth grade that I built up this
anger that I used as fuel to then later
compete and fight and do all of these
things so that I wouldn't be taken
advantage of again effectively right I
mean there was just a coping mechanism
and now I've realized that anger is very
often not helpful and that it is the
acid that damages the vessel not that
which it is poured upon right so the the
the lion I'll read it again that
rejection filled me with so much fire
not anger not resentment not discipline
above fire how what was the self-talk
that made it fire and not anger or
resentment if that makes any sense or
how do you how do you transmute what
could be a negative response into
something that's actually helpful in a
case like this yeah I remember that
distinctly because it was the first time
I got enough courage up to sort of
submit work to it to a ward site thing
and the rejection was so in-your-face
like you suck basically don't do this
that you because it was so it was almost
a caricature of a rejection like you
suck don't do this like no one would
ever say that but he did
that it just it almost made me laugh and
be like I'm just gonna prove you wrong
it was that kind of energy that was the
fire like I've always in those cases
I've always responded to those sorts of
moments as as motivation to prove
somebody wrong or to like prove myself
right maybe and maybe that sort of bit
of the flaw I still have to work out or
one of those two but I just wanted to to
say okay well [ __ ] you i'm gonna show
you that i can do this and i don't even
know i don't i shouldn't even care right
like now i realize that this is like my
reaction to someone like oh who cares
about this guy cares what he thinks
about my work it's also tied to the fact
that like I just I know you know look
obviously it come from a position of
privilege to say this whole thing but
like I've just I don't let people offend
me and I have been in situations where
like for example I mentioned that I
mentioned earlier I'm Jewish I remember
in college some people called me a [ __ ]
which is a [ __ ] horrible slur and
I've had people like I walked by a penny
in there like oh you should pick that up
like I've had some of that [ __ ] right
and it's like it doesn't matter I don't
care well you know it's to me that kind
of stuff just has never upset me cuz
it's because it's like that's just a
reflection on the other person's
ignorance or point of view I've never
let that kind of stuff get to me and I
think that is that something your
parents instilled in you I mean that's
not the note that's not the most common
reaction yeah I don't know where it came
from I don't know where that came from
but I just never I've never remembered
ever feeling offended by anyone sort of
slight at me for whatever reason and
like look I'm you know I'm five seven so
I'm relatively short guy like there's
been those kinds of things that that you
have like there's all sorts of stuff
that you get you know um and I know a
lot of people have a way [ __ ] worse
than I do so I I totally get all of that
I'm just using like look all the only
examples I have are my own right and so
but I bet I've been in those situations
where I could see someone flipping over
it and be like what the [ __ ] that's a
horrible thing to say and how could you
ever say that somebody and I just never
felt
that way it's like okay that's where you
come from fine that's fine like I I
don't really even have the energy or the
care to try and set you right or
whatever it's not my job I don't really
want to do it I it is what it is a kind
of disrupt once's off me in a sense but
one thing one reaction I have had is
motivation that's the thing that I've
always had when someone says I can't do
something or or I'm not this enough from
not that enough it's motivation to prove
prove that wrong and I don't know if
it's the the the dark and dirty side of
it is like is it actually revenge or is
it motivation and I'm not sure that I
necessarily know what that is maybe I
think it's motivation but maybe it's
more revenge which is a pretty crappy
emotion or whatever that would be called
but I never do it trying to hurt
somebody so maybe it is motivation not
revenge but I'm not totally sure to be
honest I don't know where it came from
but I just never remember ever being
angry about something that someone said
about me or how they've judged me or
whatever I just never really cared well
to maybe provide a contrast to that it
it seems like you have an abhorrence for
wasting time yes yes it seems like
you've a strong dislike for wasting time
and you've you've talked about this
before written about it
what rules for yourself Commandments
systems anything do you have in place to
help minimize time wasting so something
I think I mentioned I wrote this up in
your book actually as a response it's
sort of first what getting better at
saying no is the critical thing to begin
with and being honest about the things
you really want to do and things you
really don't want to do and not sort of
just doing things because you feel
obligated because it'll make someone
else feel good like who knows how
someone else is actually gonna feel it
sort of presumptuous to suggest that I
should do something because it'll make
someone else happy it's actually kind of
hard to know what makes people happy and
and so I try not to I try not to go down
that road because I think you can find
yourself in a difficult spot and you
know it's really hard to
so I just tried to get better at saying
no and really recognizing the things I
like to do and I don't like to do I've
kind of described my as my life is a
weird description of my life but partial
description of my life is like I just
try to do everything I can to avoid
hassles
I don't like hassles and to me a hassles
like something I don't want to do in the
future it's almost never something I
have to do now it's something I have to
do in the future and so something I've
been getting better and better at is is
is basically just being honest with
people who ask me to do things far far
in advance and say I can't make
commitments that far in advance I know
that you need a commitment that far in
advance so you're planning an event or
you're doing I totally understand that
but I I I find that I tend to this is a
strong word and it's not fair it's to
what other people are doing so it's
gonna come off strange but I don't think
of it in terms of that that they're what
they're about to do isn't worth it but I
tend to regret things that I say yes too
far in advance because not because of
the thing itself but because it actually
prevents me from having opportunities to
to to explore other things in the moment
when I get there that I might be more
interested in doing so this comes back
to the goal setting perhaps maybe it's
all the same thing which is that I don't
know how I'm going to feel six months
from now on Friday night at 4 o'clock
speaking of you know where I'm scheduled
to speak in an event maybe I'd rather
not be doing that six months from now
the only way I'm gonna know that is to
basically wait until that moment and
decide whether or not I want to do that
but of course I can't cancel on people
if I booked an events you know so I just
I've just found in in my life that the
things I put on my calendar because it's
so easy to put something far in advance
on your calendar because it cost nothing
in a sense it doesn't take any of your
time now it doesn't take any time next
week it's like you know four months from
now sure I'll do that and then it comes
up on that and like I wish I wouldn't
have said yes to that not because of the
thing itself but because of the feeling
of being now obligated to do something
that I may not choose to want to have
done in that moment had I had the choice
then or now
give us some sample language or just a
basic kind of template that you would
use to polite decline yeah
politely decline something somebody hits
you up let's just say you actually know
them they're like hey six months from
now on such-and-such a date we're having
this event ABC impressive speakers are
coming would let that blah blah blah
yeah what is your response look like
well I mean sometimes I will say yes but
most of the time I'll say I'll say you
know thanks for writing I appreciate the
invitation
I can't book anything that far in
advance right now I have a hard time
filling my calendar or six months ahead
of time or something like that I'll -
let me think about the language
basically I would say I would say I
I can't book anything that far in
advance sometimes it's because I'll be
specific like my wife is pregnant and I
like you don't like diet that's too
close so I can't do that but there's
other times I'm just like I just can't
book that far in advance if there's an
opening closer and you need someone like
let me know then I'd be happy to do it
or perhaps another time but six months
from now is just too far out for me to
book things it's kind of what I'll say
and you know I always try to first of
all it's an honor to be invited to
anything the fact that anyone wants to
hear me talk is it still surprises me
and so I'm always always appreciated I'm
sure I always make sure to lead with
that but then I just I'm honest about it
which is I can't put anything on my
calendar that foreign advance I can't
book things at 4:00 in advance
I also another thing like for example
I've been asked a lot recently to speak
internationally and I'll just tell
people which is true like I just don't
like to travel internationally for
business if I wouldn't go somewhere I'd
like to go somewhere because I you know
for personal reasons but I don't like to
travel internationally through business
so I'll just say like I'm just not
traveling internationally for business
right now it's not something I'm really
doing so I appreciate the invitation
again if you ever have an event United
States let me know that kind of stuff
because I think if you just make up
stories it's just why why not just be
honest and clear about it and and you
know people are very understanding
actually they go I totally get that
hey if we
an opening I'll let you know if not no
big deal maybe another time maybe
there's some other thing we have coming
up that's that sooner I said yeah of
course let me know if something sooner
that'd be that'd be great
so it kind of do it that way and by the
way this this sort of inspired by and I
don't know if this is true I read
somewhere that Warren Buffett kind of
does this with meetings I don't know if
again I don't know if this is true I
read it which is that if you want to
meet with him
you basically have to write his
assistant or whatever the day before so
if you if you if you write I'm sure
there's exceptions to this rule but in
most cases if you want to meet with him
you can't say hey I'd like to meet with
you know I'm gonna be in Omaha in March
March 22nd can I can I you know meet up
with mr. Buffett or something and the
answer would be when you get in on the
21st email me then and if he has any
openings the next day then he'd be happy
to meet with you and now of course he's
Warren Buffett people people have
written about this do you like oh he's
Warren Buffett like the thing is is that
yeah he's Warren Buffett but you are you
and your time is yours just like his is
his and his attention is his and yours
is yours and who cares how wealthy he is
what does it have to do with any of this
who cares what position he's in I
understand it like yeah he is in a
position where he can maybe say no more
frequently than others but so can a lot
of people I don't think people give
themselves enough credit and give no
enough credit and defend their own
attention and time as they as much as
they should
people will protect money they'll
protect all sorts of things but they
won't protect their attention in their
time and and I think more people should
get better at that so I've been
practicing getting better at that it was
sort of inspired in part by by hearing
about if it's true or not
I don't know but hearing about how about
it does that and how people respond to
the boundaries that you set particularly
if you do so tactfully tells you quite a
lot about yeah the the nature of your
true relationship that's true too with
these people I remember one time I was
going through a very difficult period
and was trying to set up a number of
different rules to
simplify and clear my calendar and it
also just took me a long time to get
back to people even people I cared quite
a lot about but the people who are
really close to me know that that is the
case who knows I could be lost in the
Amazon jungle for three weeks like they
don't get too upset about things and at
one point I got got an angry text from
this more of an acquaintance a very
powerful guy and he said he was like Tim
dude what the hell like you're harder to
get ahold of than the president I just
talked to him last week or so like that
and then we hopped on the phone he was
really upset and I said well the
president has a bigger team than I do
and number one and like number two like
I hate to say it but you're being really
aggressive right now like of all the
things on my list of priorities
including my family and this and I
mentioned a few things that were pretty
heavy like you're kind of number 17
right now and that doesn't mean that
you're unimportant to me but it means
you just have to wait until I'm done
with the first 16 so like if yeah if you
can't do that I get it I suppose but
it's not going to change and it's a it's
definitely a learned skill means
absolutely and you've maybe had this
experience but when my first book came
out I was so absolutely astonished that
anyone would pay me anything to talk
about anything that I said yes to
everything that came in and then six
months later I was like oh my god I feel
like I'm in Death of a Salesman like
this is yeah this is awful and over time
to become better at setting parameters
you've mentioned up there now Warren
Buffett clear thinking and clear writing
which you seem to value very highly and
in doing a little bit of homework for
this conversation I've read and you can
tell me if this is true or still the
case but how one of your top hiring
criteria is whether the person is a
great writer whether the person can
communicate well in written form is at
liberty to
say whether that is still the case or
not and why that is the case yeah it's
definitely the case it's sort of been
the case for it forever for us it's the
case because first of all most
communication is written these days it
first of all let me step back like we're
remote company so especially most of
communication is written if you're gonna
have if you're in a local company and
you're having meetings all the time
sometimes verbals enough but for most in
most cases people are writing more and
more and more than they ever have before
and one of the most costly and
inefficient things is having to repeat
yourself or answer questions about
something that should have been clear in
the first place it's it's really quickly
if you can't communicate clearly you're
communicating probably three or four
times more frequently than you need to
and that can be really inefficient
and really frustrating extremely
frustrating so we've always looked at
writing as a clear writing as a
prerequisite for every position we have
with a company because everybody is
supposed to communicate with themselves
with the rest of the company with their
team and most of it's done done via
written word and we also for example the
first by the way the first the first
sort of gatekeeper of it is the is the
cover letter so when people apply for a
job if they don't if they just like sent
a resume or whatever they're out
instantly that's not even something we
look at I always read our I always want
to see a cover letter of some sort it
can it can just be an email of course
with it with an attachment of the resume
or whatever but I want to see how you
how you open the conversation you know
how do you describe yourself why are you
applying for this job and not just any
job and you can tell very quickly if
someone's gonna if someone can explain
themselves if someone can advocate for
themselves and advocate for their ideas
and their position and who they are and
why they should work here if they're if
they're clear minded if they're friendly
all that stuff comes through in writing
I think if you pay enough attention to
the words you can see a lot of that and
also for example when I hire designers I
look at their design but I look at their
writing almost a little bit more
whenever we we hire designer
well we get down to the last five
candidates that we really think could be
finalists we hire them to do a project
for us 1,500 bucks for a week and they
do a project for us so we can kind of
see their actual work but even more
importantly is we ask them to write up
why they did what they did because
there's a lot of great designers out
there but people have to advocate for
themselves and so I want to see why they
do what they did I want to hear their I
wouldn't well not here but read their
their their point of view and their line
of thinking and how they came up with
the solutions and and that helps me when
I read that helps me understand what
would be like to work with that person
for real if I know are they able to
explain why they did what they did
are they glossing over little details
that actually matter like what is it how
do they how do they see their work and
how do they write about it
it's a very important part of the job
here at Basecamp so yeah so writing is
important in every position it doesn't
matter what position you're in you still
have to be a great writer
we typically start by looking at the
cover letter the the actual like work
assignments to get hired here typically
involved writing no matter what what the
position and I just think it's it's
always proven in our case to be a really
good indicator of someone's success here
whenever we've been so we hire someone
or like I don't know that the writing
wasn't quite right it almost always pans
out that it turns out that they're not
the right fit for the company even if
their work was great but they're just
unable to really convince people and
persuade people based on their sort of a
missing bit of it's not magic but I'll
call it that in the writing or you know
where you read something about this is
this is great this I'd look to dig a
little deeper on the example you gave
with the design finalists so you're
hiring for a position you have a handful
of folks you've narrowed it down to and
you're paying you're gonna pay each of
them $1500 for a one-week project do you
assign them a project give them a range
of projects could I love a little bit
more in terms of specifics and then when
you ask them like why did you do what
you did what you ended up doing
do you provide them with guidelines for
how to answer that or you keep it
totally open-ended I'd look through just
to walk us through a hypothetical a real
example of what the
project could look like and how it
unfolds from there yeah and the first of
all the reason why we do that is because
you basically can't trust anyone's
design work in the past and the reason
why is because a lot of people work with
other people
and you don't really really know what
they did like you will get will get you
know resumes like I did Nike comm it's
like no you didn't I can't tell what you
did exactly and so you'll see a lot of
that or you'll see people share
screenshots with you of things and
you're like you know I just don't know
the process that went into that so it's
hard for me to judge it it's not but I
don't think that works good or bad it's
none of that it's like I just don't know
what I'm evaluating here so the idea is
that once we get down to the five
finalists after looking at work and
looking at writing and the whole thing
we five people could be great fit for
this particular position we give them
all the same assignment and the
assignment is sometimes there's actually
there's sometimes there is a choice like
two or three different assignments but
for the most part historically it's been
one lately we've been doing a few but
it's been one where everybody who's
applying for this job does the same
project everyone gets a week to do it
they have to figure out how to fit that
in with the rest of their there most
people have jobs already so they've
maybe have to work at night or whatever
they do it and we're you know I'm well
aware of the fact that they don't have a
lot of time so I'm not expecting
perfection this is part of the reason
why I look at the writing and the
explanation of the work because I
recognize that you know who knows maybe
you have a full-time job maybe you have
kids at home maybe you don't make
whatever it is whatever it is maybe
you'll have an hour a day to do this on
the side and you're already tired I get
all of that so I'm more interested in
the in you know how you approach the
project and how you describe what you
did and why you did it so anyway they
would do for example we take a screen
from Basecamp and say so to get get
really specific about this like here's
that here's the way you add people to a
Basecamp project um what would you do to
make this better now you have no data
you're not talking to anybody about it I
just want to know what you would do like
what would what would you do because a
lot of the work at Basecamp is all based
on what would you do we don't
we don't do a lot of user testing we
don't do we do use customer interviews
and stuff but we don't get into a
testing lab we don't watch people use
our product we don't do any of that so
and we don't really look that much it
like usage data to really determine what
we're gonna do so a lot of this is about
gut and feel and in what would you do
what's wrong with this screen in your
opinion and really interesting people's
opinions I want people to have a point
of view when I hire them I don't want
people to say well I need this data and
that data to make decisions I go yeah I
get all that but what would you do I
wouldn't know what you I'm hiring you
what would you do so anyway so they do
the work and then they present it and I
say I say present it any way you want so
there are no guidelines I just say
present it any way you want but what I
guess the one guideline is like I want
to understand why you did what you did
so some people present this work is like
an elaborate website with a bunch of
different screens some people presented
as a PDF a static PDF some people write
something up and sort of tell a linear
story with screenshots interspersed
there's a variety of different ways
people do it but ultimately I'm looking
at the explanation of the work and that
and the and that's sort of the the the
thought behind the ideas that are
presented that's what I'm most curious
about it's not necessarily where the
work is great because you're already a
finalist so I already know that you're
capable of designing things well what I
want to make sure I understand is is
where the ideas are coming from how
they're filtering through your head how
they're filtering through your fingers
into the design itself and and why you
did what you did and can you defend it
one of the things is even when I
disagree with the solution I'm I'm
always gonna push back on it in these
kind of situations because I want to see
how people take criticism as well that's
a big part of this which is like
constructive criticism and critique I
want to see that one of the things we
don't do and we don't believe in at all
are like these riddles and this [ __ ]
test crap the McKinsey how many golf
balls can you fit in the 747 type stuff
yeah like everything we try to do at
Basecamp is about real stuff so like
this is actually a real project that we
would take on it's not [ __ ] and it's
real so that's it riddles and stuff
forget it so real work I want to see how
you explain it what you do with it
you do what you do with it and I'm gonna
push back on and see how you respond on
it or responded with it and that says a
lot one of the designers we hired
recently for iOS Tara man is her name
and and one of the things I was really
impressed with when she delivered her
project we start talking about it was
that when we were going through it she
goes you know I don't even know if I
like what I did here and I loved that
because that shows first of all a real
sense of confidence in like talking to
an employer I don't even know if I liked
what I did here like that's most people
like this is the best thing in the world
this isn't the best idea ever like this
is but she's like you know I think I
like it but I'm not totally sure and I
like that we dug into that and then we
got into like why she didn't think it
was great and that was just a very real
conversation that I felt like I could
work with someone like this absolutely
because they're they don't think that
everything they do was gonna be great
and they're they're self-aware enough to
recognize that and we can talk it
through and figure it out and that was
that was a great thing so there could
have been for example in this case there
weren't but there could have been five
designers who were better than her
visually anyway I still would have gone
with her because of her sort of her
approach to the work and her honesty
about it that's what I'm looking for
when I talk to somebody who I'm about to
hire what would be an example of pushing
back but let's just create a
hypothetical or a real example yeah and
then what would trip the wire as far as
red flags go or positive indicators sure
so I can't really it's hard to describe
that particular project because it we'd
all have to be looking at it to point
out that it could be anything I'm just
wondering I mean in other words this
pushback like wow I think this really
sucks
what say you hmm not sure how I feel
about that or is it you know something
else
yeah it's more it's more obviously the
latter I don't ever say anything sucks I
was doing that just because of it
totally yeah right the five thing to
know it's more um you know I'm not sure
that that I see why you know you went
down this road or doesn't this seem like
a lot of steps or you know this
why you know this word saved maybe it
should be preview like why is it saved
like I kind of usually push backs with
questions like I don't understand this
or help me understand this that's kind
of the real one I like to use it just
like help I don't I'm not sure I get
this can you help me understand this
but sometimes the red flags are very
they're very clear it's people hunched
down into a defensive posture and and
fight for their idea which is fine it's
good to do that sometimes but not when
it's like help me understand why you
know why you went this direction it's
like oh you know I went this direction
because I felt like it was the best
possible thing like there's some server
people get rushed about things I
actually like when someone takes a pause
and goes hmm
let me think about that well here's what
I went through to get to here like the
reason I use the word save was because
you know this this reason or that reason
or the reason I called it a draft and
not a preview is because of this and
that I'm more interested in people
retracing their steps then then just
sort of purely explaining their the
outcome that's not really that's kind of
a deeper thing but you'll see people in
design reviews who get very defensive
very quickly and they they they you can
tell that they're not listening anymore
they're just they're telling you what
they want you to listen to instead of
listening to what you have to say that's
very obvious and design reviews when
that comes up it's it's very clear so
it's that but I just fundamentally I'm
looking for a deep degree of
introspection in the work and an
understanding of how they ended up there
it's kind of like if you think about
back in you know school where you your
teacher would ask you to show the work
when you did a math problem they're
basically looking for is they're looking
to see if you understand how you came
out with the answer versus like did you
somehow memorize this or guess it's a
guy or is it lucky or did you actually
understand how you arrived there it's
kind of the same thing I want people to
show their work basically and that
doesn't mean showing like all the drafts
of the design work not like going
through previous versions it's again
coming down to explaining the the path
that they took to land where they landed
that's what I'm looking for
yeah that makes perfect sense and this
is also with the understanding that's a
very different company from base camp
but I've spent a lot of time with Matt
Mullenweg of automatic which runs
wordpress comm among other things and
she values written communication
exceptionally highly and they do all
their interviews via text and also have
every at least for a long period up
until maybe I want to say at least 50 or
100 employees had every prospective
employee knew they would have to spend
and I don't let this part of the vetting
process or post hiring a week or two
handling customer service yeah and which
also not to say it's perfect for every
company certainly but also tells you a
lot more than just how they handle a
user error yeah a customer service
situation right if they refuse to do
that what does that tell you right if
they do it early what does it tell you
there's a lot more than just the words
that come out of them yeah and you know
actually at our company everybody works
customer service also so no matter what
position you're in
every single person rotates one day
through customer service every number of
days like we have 54 employees in the
company about fifteen or sixteen on
customer support so about thirty of us
every 30 days we rotate through and do
one day of customer service and that's
another reason why it's important for
you to be able to write is because on
that one day a month or one day every 40
days or whatever you are on the front
lines speaking with customers and and
empathizing with them understanding what
what they're dealing with helping them
understand what they don't understand
helping us understand what we don't
understand all of that stuff which is
what customer services are really all
about of course it's also about like
troubleshooting and solving immediate
problems but a lot of it too is is it's
getting to the real like what what are
they really asking for and why and what
are we doing wrong on what
our blind spots to all that stuff and a
lot of that comes down to having a
conversation with the customer and all
of our customer service has done the via
email or Twitter or chat or something so
you don't have a phone although we do do
some phone support but we don't have a
phone number that you can call in for
example so it's all written so we want
to make sure that if we're gonna put
someone in front of customers they know
how to write as well so that that is a
big part of it - I didn't know that
automatic did that as far as their part
of their hiring process but I love the
idea yeah it's such a key such a key
skill for so many reasons for people who
want to become better writers better
communicators are there any books
resources exercises that you would
recommend
there is one of my favorite books is
called revising prose and the cover is
horrible it's like that's how you can
spot it yes
that's like a cd-rom and a pencil or
something it's like what I don't
understand how that happened maybe
they've revised it since but I think
it's that bad still it's it's so
horrible anyway
revising prose thank God thank God the
title is so catchy yeah exactly right
yeah but what's cool about it is that
and I forget the author you know you can
look it up and put the notes but is that
he died sex things one sentence at a
time and his his ability to to take a
sentence and cut it up and explain it
and simplify it I think it's a wonderful
skill and a great great book so it's not
really even about writing paragraphs or
stories or how to organize an outline
stuff it's like a sentence at a time and
figuring how to structure things love it
great book it's actually you know
there's this class I've talked about
before I've written a blog post about
this this class that I'd want to teach
if I ever taught a college class I think
I think one of the biggest disserve is's
that college does actually is that it
doesn't teach people to write well in
fact it teaches a lot of people
especially in mba programs to write very
poorly so true it's so true a lot of its
based on length like write a 10-page
thing and you know
so the class I always wanted to teach if
I was ever to teach would be a writing
class you don't care what the subject it
doesn't matter take a subject I want you
to write like a five page version of
that article I want you to write a
one-page version of it I want you to
write a five paragraph version a five
sentence version in a one sentence
version that's the assignment and we
would do that over and over and over and
over with different topics I don't care
the topic it doesn't matter I just want
you to be able to write at different
levels of resolution and continue to
clarify it as you cut things out to the
point where you can write it in one
sentence and of course there would be
more detail in it in the five paragraph
version all right maybe those three
pages one page three paragraphs one
sentence whatever it is but this idea of
going from writing the long piece and
then cutting it down and editing editing
is something that's rarely taught and
really getting trying to hone in on what
it is and realize and like the big idea
here is that you can realize that so
much of the stuff that you put in the
five page version this doesn't really
matter that much and actually the one
page version is probably better and
maybe the the three paragraph version is
much better than the one page version
and you there's probably a point where
you you begin to lose it but it's still
it's a great exercise so I'd love to see
that kind of writing instruction versus
length which sent like long long things
and then not actually editing this is
the other thing that that blows me away
about education this one is talking to
my son's in preschool I was talking to
the head of the school about about this
and the thing that's not taught in
schools is iteration and iteration is
everything outside of school where you
you do something and then like you you
you you know launch it or ship or
whatever and then you're on to making a
better version of that thing pretty
quickly in school we would always do
something and sort of hand it in and
that assignment would be done and then
you go on and do another assignment you
never get to revisit things in there in
the professional world you're revisiting
things all the time and I would love to
see you know you hand something it and
this like this one page two you know
five page to one page to five paragraphs
whatever that's a version of a short
term version of lycra visioning in a
sense perhaps the better way of doing
that would be you first had
in the five-page version you get it back
with notes then you're required to write
the one-page version of that but anyway
the point is is that feeling to revisit
something that you did and make it
better and hand it in and revise it
again and haman or advise it again is
something that you don't see often
sometimes you see that with drafts in a
document but it's not really quite the
same as being able to come back to the
idea so for example if you're doing
something in school and you're building
something or you're doing a science
project or whatever and you do it and
you're done you present it and it's over
like maybe a month later you're gonna
have a better idea for something that
you did and you go I want to do that
again but school isn't give you a chance
to do anything again really lets you
like unless you're stupid and you're
held back and they say you can't go for
further you know of course not stupid
that's the wrong word but like the
schools like you're you know you didn't
you didn't hit the criteria so we're
gonna let you do it again like in some
ways of course there's a lot of other
reasons why this probably isn't
necessarily a good thing for people for
kids but to get a chance to do it all
over again maybe you see it better the
second time
so anyway I would love to see revision
and iteration built into education and
this is sort of writing assignment as
sort of a way to get it done and I
pulled up this book and the cover is
truly awful like what is the CD even
doing there on top how did that happen
yeah to get to the bottom of that but
revising pros Richard a Lanham does that
sound right I think so yeah it's gotta
be because the cover is this in a CD on
top of a page with a bunch of markups on
it Richard Hale and I'm another book
that I found very helpful I haven't read
it in a very long time but it's called
simple and direct should be fairly easy
to write I don't remember the name of
the author and I had the I had the great
good fortune maybe two bit too many
modifiers on that but now that I'm
thinking about writing the great good
helpful fortune of taking a class in
college I was at Princeton undergrad
with John McPhee who's a senior writer
at The New Yorker it's one appeal to or
two at this point and the course was
called the literature of fact it was
about nonfiction writing creative
nonfiction
which doesn't mean making up 50% it
means taking fact and weaving it into a
narratives which John McVie is
exceptionally good at and actually one
book I think you would really enjoy is
called draft number four which is about
his writing process I think he'd be
fascinated by it but again from a
structural standpoint really fascinating
and it gets into the weeds which is not
for everybody but I think I think you'd
appreciate it and I remember the first
time it was a the first time we had our
writing assignments returned to us so
every week we had a seminar a which was
12 students or so we had to apply to get
in a writing assignment and then a
one-on-one session with McPhee to go
over the writing assignment that he had
already marked up and given to us and I
remember when he handed back the first
writing assignment man to all these
students had before he handed them out
he said look he didn't say look cuz
that's not what he would say but he said
he said I want you to know that you're
all good writers you can all right so I
don't want you to be intimidated by what
I'm about to hand back and say it was
bad so student by student their faces
drop and I got mine back and there was
more red ink on the page than black ink
that I typed out it really looked like
there was more reading and it became so
clear how fuzzy so much of my thinking
was how many unnecessary words there
were how much gristle and fat there was
in between the actual meat that was
necessary on the page and the reason I
bring up this this this story is that
over the course of the next few weeks as
we were learning more practicing more
and honing the sharpness of our writing
getting progressively less red ink
ideally my grades and all of my other
classes went up and there was a very
clear super clear correlation between
cleaning up my thinking and everything
else running more smoothly it was really
it could not have been more obvious and
such a such an incredibly valuable skill
it is you know something that I would
also encourage people to do is to read
Tom Petty lyrics but if you read Tom Tom
Petty has such a wonderful efficiency in
the storytelling in his lyrics and every
word really counts and there's no filler
it's and he paints these really broad
pictures with four or five words per per
phrase and really truly is I thought one
of the best I mean one of the best
songwriters of course but really a great
just a great writer in general when you
read the lyrics so I would look at look
at that and go look at the pictures he
can paint and the emotions he can evoke
and the the story he can tell with very
few words he's extremely economical with
his with his with his language or was
and it's a great thing to read so just
go like look at some of his albums go
look I'll look up the lyrics online and
and don't even most of the songs but
just read them and you go I see where
he's going with this and it's it's I
always enjoy doing that from time to
time he's just such a you so good at
that I will have to check that out
Elmore Leonard also another fantastic
one for people to look up and it makes
me think you were talking about the the
one page three four five paragraph three
paragraph one paragraph one line it
makes me think of the the Hemingway
story in one line which I'm sure I'm
gonna get slightly wrong but if
something right the used baby shoes
never worn or I [ __ ] it up yeah baby
baby shoes for sale baby shoes for sale
comma never worn ok they sort of five or
six words story it's it's a really
valuable exercise only and it's it's not
just for academic purposes as you
pointed out translates to everything
vintage watches go tell me about tell me
about the vintage watches I'm into I'm
into that I'm into vintage watches let's
see why well first of all I'm into
watches I'm into a lot of things that
seem like there could only be one way to
do it but there turns out there's a lot
of ways so for example I love chair just
like designing chairs
I don't design it myself but I love
looking at chairs which are very simp
things it's like you know you sit on
them and that's what they do and you're
like well there can only be a few ways
to do a chair but it turns out there's
so many different ways to do a chair
it's really interesting and watches are
the same thing do you have any favorite
chairs just as a side note I like a lot
of stuff that she I'm his name is French
so I'll probably get wrong but Jean
regime probe a are I'm getting that
right I love his designs his styles
there's a bunch of others out maybe I'll
send you an email afterwards to some of
my favorite chairs but I so watches are
similar in that like a watch basically
like look it's there to tell the time
some watches can do more than others but
this is there all the time and like okay
there's you got it especially if you
look at analog watches which is why it
one of the reason that like vintage
stuff is it's like you know I had a
couple hands three hands maybe or two
hands and but there's so many different
designs and so many different styles and
so many different elements and so many
different approaches to it that there's
an endless amount of curiosity in it for
me and plus the cool thing about
mechanical watches is that they're such
a it's a combination of all the things I
like so its design its engineering its
materials it's it's like patina and like
seeing age on things a lot of things
that age well it's it's art its science
like if you if you crack open one of
these watches and look at the movement
like there's serious engineering going
on in there and some science and some
really fascinating stuff and like the
idea that that mankind can capture time
and tell it this way using Springs and
gears it's kind of an amazing thing and
be that accurate so I've always sort of
I haven't always been into them but my
dad was into them still maybe still is I
don't know if he collects stuff anymore
but he used to when I was younger and I
got into them and the vintage thing I'm
actually kind of into vintage and modern
these days but more so I found vintage
in just more interesting because there's
more character in the objects because
they have time on them they actually
have you know age on them and that's
kind of cool to see how things aged and
that's one of the reasons why like I
like a lot of natural materials in
general now we're like I'm branching
into architecture discussion here but I
like brick I like wood I like things
that that pick up a Joe
time versus like a lot of modern
materials I feel like they don't age
very well they look great when you do
the photo shoot right after it's built
and then they just aged poorly and they
show their age in a way that's not
flattering but in fact it takes it to
tracks from from the quality of the
object so it's cool to see the other
thing is I'll say about vintage watches
is that it's really cool to be able to
look down on your wrist and go this
thing I have in my wrist has been
working for 50 years and if someone
looks after it five more times over the
next 50 years or next hundred years
it'll still work there's basically
nothing that is being created today or
that is true anymore
except really watches mechanical watches
most other things these days are
disposable and so it's kind of a great
reminder that you can actually build
things that last and you can look down
your wrist and go someone else 50 years
ago was looking down at the wrist seeing
the exact same thing at work just as
well
and fifty years from now my kid can look
down on his wrist or her wrist and see
the same thing I looked at to tell the
same amount of time and it's gonna work
as well and I just kind of love that
idea so anyway that's sort of why I'm
into it so a few things the first is at
some point I need to introduce you to
Peter
attea MD who's a close friend of mine
and a an extreme watch nerd okay I think
you guys would have a lot to talk about
if you could only pick and I have no
idea how many watches you have you don't
have to divulge that but if you could
only choose one two three watches to
keep do do any come to mind or you're
like yep these are definitely on the
list yes so I have a it's called a Rolex
Mill Gauss six five four one is the
model number what they would call the
reference number in the watch world
it's from 1958 and I just think it's the
coolest [ __ ] thing ever
so I just love the way that's that's so
cool looking it's it's awesome so I know
Rolex mil Gauss 65 for one from 1958
that's that's definitely one keeper I
have like an old Patek Phillipe blanking
on the reference right now it's it was
it was built for similar to this mil
Gauss that I was telling you about all
the way milligauss means 1,000
so it was a it was a it was a watch
built for scientists who worked in high
magnetic environments and watches
watches typically ventured went
especially now modern ones what a little
bit different but they don't work well
in magnetic environments because the the
spring that's inside them once it's
magnetized they can't tell time properly
anymore basically so so these watches
were built for scientists to be a
magnetic or anti-magnetic and so the
mill Gauss was one of them and then and
then Patek made one can't believe I
can't remember the reference right now
anyway you can said that you can send it
with your links to the chairs exactly
it's also an anti magnetic watch you
know sort of their answer to the mill
Gauss so it's funny that like the two
things I come to mind immediately are
like watches for scientists which you
know it's just that's what a cool niche
you know tube makes makes a product for
scientists in the fifties like how cool
like kind of if you can imagine
scientists in the 50s with their white
coats and like learning all sorts of new
things about physics in the world
biology and all sorts of really cool
stuff happened back then that those are
the two watches that immediately come to
mind that that I really really dig
there's another one actually which is a
I'm gonna get this name wrong too so I'm
just gonna call it a it it's Josh Aaron
look Colt urges you're like Colt a or
something like that I can never never
exactly know what it is anyway it's
called the Polaris from 1968 it's a dive
watch built for divers and it has an
alarm on it a mechanical alarm which is
really cool and really unique and rare
especially at the time which i think is
really beautiful and just a really neat
complication for a mechanical watch to
have an alarm on it so you can say like
for example at five o'clock I want this
thing to buzz very loudly so I would
know that it's five o'clock which of
course is so silly and easy to do with
an iPhone or any digital thing but
mechanically it's actually was quite a
challenge and very few watches it over
had a mechanical alarm I also like the
way it looks so anyway there's some of
that stuff that I'm into there's other
bunch of other things but those are the
kind of the three that initially come to
mind is ones that I'm really into
if you had to give a TED talk on
obsessions and it couldn't be related to
your company couldn't be related to
watch as these are personal obsessions
yeah what what might you talk about that
that a lot of people wouldn't know about
hmm well I don't know if I'd be able to
talk about it I'm imagining all the the
unacceptable unacceptable socially
awkward sexual fetishes that you wouldn
t able to talk about on the Ted stage
but continue
I wouldn't go to talk about it with
authority let's say let's say um one of
the things I'm really into strangely is
is prairie restoration okay so stand
back here for a second let me tell you
even though this so I maybe ten years
ago I bought a farm up in rural
Wisconsin about three hours from Chicago
where I live it's like 50 miles west of
Madison Wisconsin for those who kind of
know the geography and it's very rural
and it's kind of hilly it's very
beautiful I bought it and I'd always
wanted some land I love nature I love
just getting out and walking in nature
just this is me the most refreshing
thing you could ever do and so I bought
this land and I looked at it and I
thought it was just beautiful and
amazing and it was but I learned a
couple years in that was full of weeds
and invasive species and like not really
the way it should be or should or was
but modern farming and and and the fact
the lands been tilled a bunch of times
and there's invasive species and stuff
it sort of took over the land so I got
on this kick to to to find a prairie
restoration specialist which I learned
that there's this thing called prairie
restoration where you could sort of
bring the land back to the way it was to
Prairie in this particular part of the
country and the Prairie is in fact the
the most endangered natural habitat in
the United States there's only like
something like a thousand or something
acres left of it in the entire United
States so people talk about old-growth
forests being gone and stuff there's
actually more old-growth forests United
States and there's prairie prairies like
gone basically but I visited some actual
prairies that have been restored and
also some some that are still around and
these are due to agriculture I assume or
some basically farming yeah like all the
land has been tilled basically for
farmland and and I visit some of these
prairies and they just are the most
beautiful thing hundreds of species of
plants and flowers and and and and
shrubs and insects and birds and it's
just these this beautiful beautiful
beautiful thing and so I had this land
that's it's a quite a bit of a rage and
I and I start hiring hired this guy to
help me restore it we've been doing it
for seven eight years now or something
bringing the land back to the way it was
like five acres at a time and planting
native species and and and getting rid
of all the invasives and also doing the
same thing there's some force on the
property and I'm doing oaks of an or
restoration so a lot of invasive trees
have grown up around these big huge
beautiful oak trees that are hundreds of
years old but they've been crowded by
these other trees so we're getting rid
of some of the other trees and letting
the Oaks be the way they were and then
returning the forest floor the way it
was and it's just such a incredibly
rewarding but super slow process it
takes like you seed these prairies you
first all you have to like kind of get
rid of everything that's there and then
weeds pop up you have to get rid of
everything that's there because there's
what's called a seed bank in the soil so
the seed bank is basically hundreds of
years worth of seeds that have just been
waiting to sprout and so you have to
kind of like you clear out all the
living stuff and then like there's all
these seeds that are then now exposed in
sunlight and then they sprout you have
to basically just kind of nuke it all
for a while until there's nothing
basically left in the soil or invasive
species left in the soil and then you
can go and get native species by
actually doing seed gathering you can
gather seeds at certain prairies or you
can buy seeds native seeds you can also
find individual prairie plants in what's
called Prairie remnants which are like
small vestiges of old prairies that
might still be on your property and
harvest the seeds from those so it's
this really really slow amazing thing
then you seed it and it might take five
or six years for a prairie to grow
because prairie plants typically
invested all their energy in the first
few years and in the roots so you don't
see anything growing it's really
frustrating it looks like [ __ ] for a
long time and all the sudden there is it
it starts to come up and then it's just
so rewarding and so wonderful to walk
through
and so that's something that I'm really
into in a deep way and probably most
people don't know about it in general I
didn't know about it so few years ago
but I loved it so much and I'm kind of
on this crusade now to like this anti
Korn crusade you know I want to
basically whatever land comes up next to
my land I want to buy it because most of
its corn and corn is sort of at the root
of a lot of different problems and I
just want to like get rid of the corn
and return the land of the way it was
and sort of create this patchwork of
land and then eventually put it some
sort of trust so it can never be touched
and there can always be these these
beautiful tracts of land forever
of course it have to be maintained and
now to have to be how the trust to have
to be able to figure that out maybe part
of it is farm to fund that but anyway
that's something that I would probably
love to talk about although I don't know
enough about it
to give a TED talk but I can certainly
talk someone's ear off for about an hour
on a little detail that I've learned
what a fantastic project it's such a fun
thing that it's so sounds therapeutic
too in the sense that having to embrace
slowness in at least one compartment of
your life seems to be a nice
counterbalance to potentially external
or internal drives not necessarily in
you but in a lot of people certainly
myself included at times to do bigger
things faster no down the other thing
about that I'll say is that you can't
even speed this process up if you wanted
to and that's what's so awesome about it
and by the way the process is multi
layer multi-layered and multi-tiered and
probably by this point you're like I
should never pass in this class anyway
real quick what's cool about it too is
not only do the plants like new plants
come up and all sorts of species bloom
but you start to see new insects and new
insects come a few years later and they
stage somehow you're like where'd they
come from and like they're so out there
but they find it and they and they and
they're there they're wired to
proliferate in these environments and
then you see new birds and new bird
species there's like a hundred and
something bird species now on my
property when originally there weren't
there was like 40 and you know where
they come from and they just come from
they find it somehow and they come in
and then like the other thing I've been
learning is if you build a pond for
but I don't have any pawn but I have a
river but if there's a pond if you just
fill a pond with water within a few
years you will have fish and you're like
what how does that happen like how could
that possibly be and it turns out like
fish are you know a bird might be eating
a fish and drop it before it's dead and
it pops into there and that could have
been a pregnant fish and before you know
it like the whole thing is like life
it's just waiting for so it's not
waiting it's everywhere but like if you
restore a proper you restore some some
some bland and give it some space and
let it do what it does nature is so so
resilient and just once to thrive and
it's so cool to watch it happen on its
own schedule and say in nature isn't it
never it's never in a hurry that's the
thing that I love so much about it is
that it's never in a hurry but it
accomplishes everything and that's a
quote that I read somewhere and I don't
know where I read it who said it but I
loved it and I always think about it
which is that it'll take its time you
know get wherever it needs to get done
done and however long it takes it takes
which is such an analog or it's such an
opposite non analog and opposite to
humanity which is always rushing which
is actually typically destroying and
which is getting faster and faster and
faster and I don't think it's you know
the right path but it is what it is
thank you for sharing oh yeah I love
that it also makes me think about how
much of life is setting the conditions
for good things to happen not trying to
force good things and and to give
another example that the a biohacker
slash nutrition crab might be interested
in is the contrast between probiotics
where you're say swallowing bacteria you
hope will take root in your gut among
other things right which often does not
work very well can contrast it with free
biotics where you're consuming different
types of foodstuffs it could be certain
types of fiber baobab root for instance
which is effectively this is very
simplified but restoring the soil
conditions in your gut so that the types
of bacteria you want to grow naturally
begin to take root and grow
and you can't just take a handful of
seeds like drive them into the ground
expecting them to pop out overnight
it just doesn't doesn't work that way
and so thinking about setting the
conditions is something I've been
thinking a lot about setting the
conditions for positive emergent
properties and then secondly you know
just think about this today because I
was watching a documentary last night
where this mother was giving her son
advice and she said I just want you to
learn patience you need to learn
patience and you I've been to see I
thought over the years a lot about this
word and whether I need more or less
patience and I was thinking today that
it's maybe it's unproductive to think of
it in terms of more or less patience but
rather in terms of developing the
ability to discern between the things
that can and should be accelerated and
the things that can't be accelerated and
if you attempt to accelerate then we'll
just do more damage related to that I
mean I love this idea that you're
bringing up about about probiotics
versus prebiotics and creating the
conditions for growth or creating
conditions for desired outcomes or
whatever and I'm gonna tie it all back I
mean we're tying this like let me tie
like prairie restoration to business
building which is and and gut building
basically and and you know that gut
health and the whole thing which is that
part of the - is not only creating the
conditions for things to thrive but also
not creating conditions for certain
things to thrive so something for
example our business is self-funded yeah
we did take money from Bezos in 2006 but
that was a personal founder shares none
of its money ever went to our business
David and I took some money off the
table so we've been a hundred percent
bootstrapped and funded by customers
ever since day one which means we've
created a situation where we don't have
to answer to anybody we don't have to be
in anyone elses timescale I don't have
to build something that I know is gonna
have to be sold in seven years because a
fund is coming due and like they need
their money out of it or I also don't
have to build something that grows at a
certain rates because you know you need
to grow at a certain rate for a certain
return we don't care about returns are
the conditions we've set are not to have
returns thrive and and you know generate
returns for others
but actually what we've tried to set up
is profit conditions for profitability
and for sustainability because as long
as we make more money than we spend we
can exist for as long as we want there's
no external pressures artificial
pressures that we've set up are
conditions that we've created that will
force us to make a decision about when
we have to sell the business at some
point so it's not only about creating
conditions for thriving it's about like
in fact putting up barriers for certain
things not to happen and I've been
thinking a lot personally about putting
a lot I've been putting a lot of energy
into making sure certain things don't
happen versus putting energy into make
sure certain things do happen and I
think if you can prevent a lot of things
from happening by thinking about what
you don't want you do create the
conditions and for other things to come
in which are the things that you
actually do want so I think there's a
lot of similarities here between nature
and business and and you know gut health
is nature as well of course and
conditions and letting things sort of
thrive and preventing other things from
happening it's cool like for example we
have hundreds over 100 species of birds
now on the property we didn't put
birdseed out like you know you don't put
birds so you know what you do is you put
seed out that grows in the ground that
then creates the conditions where
actually it grows seed so it does
actually grow bird seed right it grows
bird seed it just takes five years and
then birds find it and they're like
everything just happens the way it
naturally should at the right pace and
the right scale and it's just very
rewarding to see that happening and I
think it does color your your impression
of other things and sort of shows you in
many ways how sort of silly speed is in
a lot of other things where it's
injected unnecessarily and sort of the
damage that it does absolutely yeah
absolutely
it's the topic we go on and on with for
four hours I'm sure it's maybe we should
do that at some point but let me wrap up
with just a just a few more questions
and one one of them I've asked you
before and this will sound familiar
and then I'll pause for a second buy a
little time but if you could have a
giant billboard anywhere with anything
on it what would it say and why right it
could be a quote could be a word could
be a question could be anything it could
be someone else's quote
now I ask you this question in tribal
mentors and you get you said one of
these quotes and you gave about 15 to 20
okay maybe more 25 fantastic quotes I
mean these are these are excellent
quotes but right now in your life
doesn't have to relate to anything in
the external wider world a little let me
read a few just to get people taste and
then I'd love to know which one you
would pick sure right now in your life
but let me pick a few here if you think
you're too small to be effective you've
never been in the dark with a mosquito
Betty Reiss every great cause begins as
a movement becomes a business and
eventually degenerates into a racket
Eric Hoffer this one has proven very
popular the fairest rules are those to
which everyone would agree if they did
not know how much power they would have
John Rawls and I'll read I'll read one
more since we've mentioned him a few
times price is what you pay value is
what you get Warren Buffett where where
would you go at this point in your life
with a message a word a quote a question
anything on a gigantic billboard
metaphorically of course getting a
message out to millions or billions of
people yeah well I think it'd be fun
just to say the word billboard on a
billboard and just leave pay for it pay
for for a hundred years and there it is
it's called billboard what would be fun
but also gag I like that that John Rawls
quote so much which is the fairest rules
are the ones you would I forget can you
agree they are the fairest rules of
those to which everyone would agree if
they did not know how much power they
would have yeah that to me is at the
root of so many things we've been
dealing with a little bit of this in our
in our own business it's a little bit
slightly different but just like
information asymmetry and recognize that
everybody has the same information so
they look at things through different
lenses and it's very important to
recognize the fact that you can't just
come at something one way because you
know it if someone else doesn't know it
you can't assume that they knew that and
you know there's it's the same sort of
idea which is which is you almost you
can't be upset when someone has a
reaction to something when they just
have a different set of information and
similarly you know
you the rules are you know rules are
based on like who has the power to make
them basically today that's kind of how
it is in almost everything and so it's a
good reminder that rules basically are
the Feres to those who make them
unfortunately but they would be the
fairest if no one knew who they applied
to and it's just a good reminder on a
lot of different levels it's one of my
favorite quotes and I think that's
probably something I would put up on a
billboard it'd be hard to read at 70
miles an hour to speed by it which is
why I still like billboard but as a
quote I think it's the most meeting one
of the most meaningful quotes and most
important quotes to keep in mind
whatever it is that you do definitely
and I'll read I'll read one more just
because actually I read two more of your
quotes because there are many to choose
from I here's one that applies certainly
to a few things we've talked about the
conversation quote not everything that
can be counted counts and not everything
that counts can be counted William Bruce
Cameron and then the next and last when
all read is by Albert Schweitzer in the
hopes of reaching the moon men fail to
see the flowers have lost another feet
yeah I've got a story but that's maybe
for another time about that quote well
you know let's do it let's just go ahead
do it sure so I don't know a number of
years ago I was invited to to go to this
John Maeda invited me to go to this
thing at the glass house in New Canaan
Connecticut I think it is the Philip
Johnson glass house and it was like a
summit on simplicity and there was I
think 10 or 15 people invited and one of
the people invited was was this older
man's Japanese man I think he was in his
80s or close to it almost everyone else
was much younger much much younger 20s
and 30s 40s maybe and like I said
earlier I love I love older people so I
sort of gravitated to him he was really
well-dressed and Justin seemed
interesting and I noticed that he was
whenever we were going so the Philip
Johnson Glass House the whole campus I
think is about 50 acres and there's
maybe a dozen different buildings and
it's kind of a neat idea because Philip
Johnson had this idea that it's actually
one building the hallways are just
outside
which is kind of a cool thought but
really it's like twelve different
buildings like for example as all he has
an office which was a separate building
which doesn't have a bathroom doesn't
employing because he didn't need it
because it's like it's so part of the
house that has plumbing except to walk
outside to get there anyway we were
walking between these houses and you
have a 50 acre site so there's quite a
bit of distance between these buildings
and I noticed that this guy was always
last in the line to walk and I kind of
sat back with him on one of the walks
and and you know I didn't but he's also
like it wasn't because he was old that
would be the first thing you would think
that he's just older so he's gonna walk
slower but actually he's like no and I
could tell that he was physically able
to walk as fast as everybody else it
wasn't that he goes no everyone's just
walking too fast and they're missing
things as they go he was so he just
kneeled down and he looked he took like
this square foot of ground and and by
the way I had noticed as he was walking
he was looking down as well so he's
walking slowly and looking down and he
just he kind of took the square foot of
flint and like pointed out some flowers
and some insects and some shapes and
some stuff and says like this is
beautiful people feel like they have to
go all over the world to see something
new all they have to do is look down and
if you walk slowly and look down like
there's a world under your feet all the
time in an interesting world and he goes
these people ahead of me they're younger
yeah maybe they can walk a bit faster
but look at everything they're missing
and I just that really just kind of
totally smacked me in the face I loved
this point like yeah they're going
faster and they look like they're going
somewhere but look at everything they're
missing along the way and so that point
about that other quote that you just
brought up about going to the moon
missing the flowers like that's sort of
similar thing which is you know
especially today where everyone's
rushing all over the place trying to get
somewhere good where are you actually
going and what are you actually missing
and I thought that that that moment this
guy actually stopping and physically
explained that to me and looking down
and pointing out some things was a
really poignant thing and something I
always have always remembered since then
what a lovely story yeah he's a lovely
man I think he's still around I'm sure
yet from I understand he's he's a
Japanese garden expert he has an amazing
Japanese garden
his backyard somewhere in Northern
California and he's also like a wine
connoisseur and supposed to be a really
fascinating guy I never really caught up
with him afterwards I always meant to
and I missed that opportunity and I
should probably figure out how to get
touch with him but a wonderful man
really interesting person and I
appreciate the lesson he taught me there
well if you track him down let me know
sounds like a little maybe the top
person I got hot cast yeah yeah
definitely someone who can really
embrace the the joy of missing out yeah
Jason well this has been so much fun I
really appreciate you taking the time
today to chat with me and share your
stories with the world also well thanks
for having me this is super fun it's
always fun to talk to you and thanks for
giving me so much time to do that my
pleasure and is there is there anything
else before we wrap up that you would
like to ask of the audience suggest to
the audience any closing comments of any
time nope I don't have any actually I
like answering questions so I don't I
don't have any proclamations or anything
to share so I don't if anyone wants to
get in touch I think you'll have some of
that stuff so feel free to hit me up on
Twitter or wherever oh the other thing
actually I will mention um David and I
DHH and I are doing this new YouTube
channel which is kind of a something
people been asking for for a while we're
calling it getting real and we're
basically showing what our like kinda
like you asked me like what's your day
like what do you people always like
what's your morning like and what do you
do like well why don't I just show you
so we're doing these videos of actually
walking through code samples walking
through design decisions walking through
design reviews and making them all
public so I think it's kind of a neat
thing to check out if you're interested
in sort of how we look at design and how
we look at code and how we look at
writing one of the things actually did
was I wrote an article for Inc recently
and I just recorded my screen and sort
of talked out loud as I was writing it
to sort of show like here's how I read
an article I don't start with an outline
I start with the blank sheet I've got
kind of just right and then I was sort
of doing the director's cut as I went
and editing is editing live as I went
and it's sort of a fun sort of thing so
I'm doing some of that which would be
kind of fun to follow people are
interested in that other than that
everything else too to share you've
you've written a lot and do you have
many popular articles essays blog posts
etc online e you
someone wanted to start with one or two
are there one or two that you could
mention as a gateway drug into the mind
of Jason well speaking based on our
conversation today there was this the
article I wrote about like I've never
had a goal which would be a good thing
to start reading I think or a good place
to read I think probably it's on it's on
our blog signal versus noise which is on
medium if you search for my name on
Google and say never had a goal you'll
probably land I try to be a good jason
freed never had a goal that's a good one
to read and then I also wrote one about
not having expectations which might be
another interesting thing to look at if
there's any other ones I'll I mean there
are some other ones but I'm not sure if
they'd be good places to start but those
might be a good place to start
great and I'll include shares maybe
prairie restoration the Polaris watch
I'll send you all that will include all
that the show notes for people listening
you'll be able to find all of that at
tim dot blog forward slash podcast and
just search jason and he'll pop right up
and you can find all these links and
more as well as every other episode and
jason at some point maybe we'll do a
round two and it'd be lovely to see you
in person sometime yeah you're down
where are you now i'm in austin texas
okay you're not an okay well uh at some
point yeah we'll run into each other
again but i'd love to do it again and if
we want to do it personally be even
better so let me know i'm around
definitely yep you know austin texas
it's the third coast as they say you
need water to be a coast I mean at least
yeah we have lakes we do have some
creeks we're not River entirely dry
there are rivers so we do we do have
that but to be continued and to everyone
out there on the interwebs and beyond as
always thank you for listening be safe
or not and pay attention to what's under
your feet
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday and that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com
I love WordPress I have used it for so
many years it's my go-to platform for
blogging and creating websites I use
wordpress.com for everything every day
my site tuna blog is built on it the
websites for my books including tools of
tightenings
tribe of mentors it's all in or desktop
and the founder Matt Mullenweg when my
close friends has appeared on this show
many times the search met Mullenweg
tequila Ferriss or quite an exciting
time whether you're looking to create a
personal blog business site or both you
can make a really big impact right out
of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be in good
company
it's used by the New Yorker jay-z
Beyonce 5:38 TechCrunch Ted CNN and
times just to name a handful and one of
my friends at Google children nameless
pissed home Heath that WordPress comm
offers the quote best out of the box
SEO imaginable
it's one of the many reasons that nearly
30% of the Internet is run on WordPress
you do not need experience or to hire
something perhaps the best part where
press comm guide you through the entire
experience they have hundreds of designs
and templates that you can use and it's
easy to get started there's no need to
worry about security upgrades posting
any of that down for 24/7 support and
they're very very responsive your
questions they get right back to you and
this allows you to create the highest
quality with the least amount of
headache and friction so if you're
building a website period my friends
come to me and ask what I use what I
recommend they use the answer is
wordpress.com so check it out you want
to get started today learn more with a
15% discount off any new plan go to
wordpress.com forward slash Tim create
your website and find the plan is right
for you to learn more take a look
wordpress.com for slash Tim 15% off your
brand website check it out
this episode's brought to you by peloton
and I'd heard about peloton over and
over again but I ended up getting a
peloton bike in the whole system after I
saw my buddy Kevin rose I've known him
forever
some of you know and he showed up at my
gate at my house a while back and he
looked fantastic hey I asked dude you
look great
what the hell have you been up to be
she's always doing a weird diet or
another but it only last it's like a
week or two so he always regresses to
the mean after like 75 beers and he said
I've been doing peloton five days a week
now that caught my attention cuz Kevin
does nothing five days a week and you
know I love you Kevin but it really
piqued my curiosity ended up getting a
system and it's become an integral part
of my week I love it and I really didn't
expect to love it at all because I find
cycling really boring usually but
peloton is an indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home
you have to worry about fitting classes
in your schedule or making it to a
studio with some type of commute etc new
classes are added every day and this
includes options led by elite New York
City instructors in your own living room
you can even livestream studio classes
taught by the world's best instructors
or find your own favorite class on
demand and in fact Kevin and I rarely do
live classes and you can compete with
your friends which is also fun Kevin I'm
coming after you but we usually just use
classes on demand I really like Matt
wilfers and design high intensity
training sessions that are shorter like
20 minutes and I think Kevin's favorite
is Alex and everyone seems to have their
favorite instructor or you can select by
music duration and so on each peloton
bike includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen
performance tracking metrics I think
that along with the real-time
leaderboard are the main reasons that
this caught my attention when cycling
never had caught my attention before
it's really pretty stunning what they've
done with the user interface to keep
your attention the belt drive is quiet
and it's smaller than you would expect
so it can fit in a living room or in
office I actually have it in a large
closet believe it or not and it fits
with no problem so peloton is offering
all of you guys listeners of the Tim
Ferriss show a special offer and it is
actually special visit one peloton
that's o-n-e PE l OT on1 peloton comm
and enter the code Tim all caps TI m at
checkout to receive $100 off accessories
with your peloton bike purchase now you
might say black accessories wait I don't
need fancy towels or whatever other
supplemental bits and pieces no the
shoes you need you need the clip and
shoes and those are in the accessory
category so this hundred dollars off is
a very legit hundred dollars off so if
you want to get in your workouts if you
want a convenient and really
entertaining way to do high-intensity
interval training or anything else or
you just want to get a fantastic gift
for someone
check out pillows on one pallet on Comm
and enter the code to Tim
Oh any PE l o t-- o-- n calm and enter
the goat image checkout to receive $100
off any accessories including the shoes
that you will want to get check it out
one peloton comm code Tim
[Applause]
you